Nach zwei Monaten ist er am Tisch gestanden. Wir waren ja in so einem Großraumbüro, aber ich war alleine. Und dann sagt er, meine Nachfolge ist noch nicht geregelt, hab ich gesagt. Gib Gas, wenn du auf Uli Hoeneß folgst. Dann wissen sie, was sie getan haben. Wir hatten nach dieser Chelsea-Niederlage Auseinandersetzung, die ich diese Woche, wäre ich mein ganzes Leben lang nicht vergessen.
Was ist da passiert?
Auf der einen Seite sagt er öffentlich, okay, es war eine riesen Enttäuschung, dass ich gegangen bin. Auf der anderen Seite ruft er dich an und hilft dir beim Kreuzbandriss. Und das sind natürlich Momente, die du nie vergisst.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem Überraschungstribünengespräch. Das war so nicht geplant, aber es ist was ganz Besonderes. Und ich freue mich, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und dass ihr jetzt das hier hören könnt. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Und hier an dieser Stelle moderiere ich ja eigentlich gerne tiefergehende Gespräche im Tribünengespräch. Manchmal haben wir da Portraits, manchmal widmen wir uns bestimmten Themen. Und diese Sendung, die ist eine Ausnahme von beidem. Denn das, was ihr jetzt hier gleich hören werdet, ist ein Gespräch, das schon einmal in der Öffentlichkeit stattgefunden hat und das auch nicht von mir moderiert wurde. Aber es war so schön moderiert und es war inhaltlich so interessant, was vor allem am Gast Christian Nerlinger lag, dass wir gefragt haben, können wir das vielleicht auch im Rasenfunk veröffentlichen? Und da kann ich mich ganz, ganz herzlich beim ganzen Team vom Deutschen Fußballmuseum in Dortmund bedanken, die gesagt haben, ja klar könnt ihr das machen, könnt ihr gerne verwenden. Knut Hartwig, der Moderator, Christian Nerlinger, der Gast. Und dann war ich noch als zweiter Gast zugeladen. Wir alle haben uns unterhalten über Uli Hoeneß. Anlass war die Veröffentlichung meines Buchs Aus Liebe zum Spiel, Uli Hoeneß, das Geld und der Deutsche Fußball. Erschienen bei DTV über 400 Seiten für 15 Euro. Wer von euch den 11 Leben Podcast kennt, der weiß auch schon, was meine Arbeit zu Uli Hoeneß bedeutet. Das Ganze gibt es jetzt auch zum Verschenken und nochmal zum Selberlesen. Und das war der Anlass für diesen Abend, der am 15. Januar 2023 im Fußballmuseum in Dortmund stattgefunden wurde. Tolle Location, über 200 Gäste vor Ort, hat ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Und es war eben einfach eine schöne Diskussion, ein schönes Gespräch, das wir in voller Länge hier verwenden dürfen. Dafür ganz herzlichen Dank ans Deutsche Fußballmuseum. Hat wirklich großen Spaß gemacht. Und ich denke, auch euch wird es freuen, dass ihr das jetzt hier hören könnt. Ihr werdet jetzt eben dann gleich Knut Hartwig, den Moderator hören, Christian Nerlinger, den muss ich nicht weiter vorstellen, und auch ein bisschen mich. An zwei Stellen lese ich auch kurze Episoden aus dem Buch vor, also ein bisschen Lesungsfeeling bekommt ihr auch. Ganz hinten dran haben wir noch Fragen aus dem Publikum. Und dann, glaube ich, werdet ihr die nächsten zwei Stunden gut unterhalten sein. Und das liegt am allerwenigsten an mir. Ich glaube, das ist an dieser Stelle schon klar geworden. Ich bin sehr dankbar, dass wir das hier veröffentlichen dürfen. Also, ich wünsche euch jetzt viel Spaß. Ich übergebe jetzt an Knut Hartwig. Viel Spaß mit diesem Tribünengespräch.
Ja, herzlich willkommen, guten Abend hier im Deutschen Fußballmuseum. Viele, die sich für Fußball interessieren oder auch schon mal ins Stadion gehen, können damit umgehen. Bei ausverkauften Haus heißt es in der Regel immer, wir fangen ein paar Minuten, der Spielbeginn verzögert sich ein paar Minuten. Aber ich glaube, wir sind noch in einer akzeptalen Zeit an diesem auch für uns ungewöhnlichen Abend oder außergewöhnlichen Abend, weil sonntags abends haben wir eigentlich noch nie was hier gemacht und jetzt noch in Konkurrenz zur Handball-WM und zum Tatort aus Dortmund. Also vielen Dank, dass ihr euch die Zeit nehmt. Und ich kann aber versprechen, bei uns wird es ja auch spannend. Und für die analogen Fernsehgucker von euch, zu denen ich mich ja auch fast zählen muss, es gibt auch Mediatheken, wo ihr das andere alles nachher noch mal nachvollziehen könnt. Bei uns wird es spannend, weil wir nämlich in 50 Jahren Fußballgeschichte, die deutsche Fußballgeschichte heute zurückschauen. Und das machen wir eigentlich regelmäßig hier. Wir haben ja eine Dauerausstellung, die ich jedem, der noch nicht drin war, auch anempfehlen möchte. Wir gucken auf 50 Jahre Fußballgeschichte zurück anhand eines Mannes, der diese Zeit so sehr geprägt hat, wie wohl kaum ein anderer im deutschen Fußball. Und es ist eine neue Biografie über ihn erschienen. Ich bin sehr froh, dass der Autor dieser Biografie, sie heißt Aus Liebe zum Spiel, heute bei uns ist. Ganz herzlich willkommen, Max Jakob Ost! Ganz besonders freue ich mich auch über einen Gast, den wir jetzt begrüßen. Ein Mann, der Uli Hoeneß über viele Jahre aus verschiedenen Perspektiven hautnah miterlebt hat. Er war Spieler beim FC Bayern München. Er war dann unter dem Titel Sportdirektor unmittelbar Nachfolger von Uli Hoeneß als Manager beim FC Bayern. Und ja, es gibt kaum einen, der über so viel Insiderwissen verfügt, wie unser Gast Christian Nerlinger. Herzlich willkommen! Jeder hat ein Mikro, genau. Max, du hast dich jetzt sehr lange mit diesem Buch beschäftigt, kann man sagen. Was hast du sonst so vorher in deinem Leben gemacht? Stell dich doch mal ganz kurz vor für die Leute, die dich noch nicht so kennengelernt haben.
Also ich bin Sportjournalist seit einigen Jahren. Ich mache einen Fußballpodcast, der heißt Rasenfunk und jeder, der den kennt, kann mal kurz die Hand heben gerne. Aha, das ist nicht repräsentativ für Deutschland, aber es freut mich sehr. In diesem Podcast spreche ich über Fußball mit Gästen. Der Podcast ist spendenfinanziert und hauptsächlich sehe ich Fußballspiele tatsächlich. Inzwischen ist es so, dass ich an jedem Wochenende alle Spiele der ersten Männerbundesliga und der ersten Frauenbundesliga sehe. Ich weiß selbst, dass das viel ist und vielleicht wird das auch nicht immer so bleiben, aber das ist eigentlich das, was ich hauptsächlich mache, Fußball gucken.
Gibt es Schlimmeres?
Allerdings.
Christian, dich braucht man ja eigentlich nicht vorstellen, aber mir ist es wichtig, auch nochmal darzulegen, du warst fünf Jahre Bayern-Bundesligaspieler, du warst zuvor schon in der Jugend. Wann bist du damals zum FC Bayern gekommen?
Ich bin mit 14 Jahren zum FC Bayern geboren, hier in Dortmund-Wampel. Ich habe eine sehr schöne Kindheit verbracht, dann nach München.
Das muss man kurz erklären, warum die Kindheit hier schön war, sondern warum du hier geboren bist, in Dortmund.
Mein Vater war auch Fußballprofi und beim FC Bayern war es damals auch schon sehr schwer, Spielzeit zu erlangen und dann hat er Umwege genommen über Kickers Offenbach und dann eigentlich eine relativ lange Station hier in Dortmund gehabt. Das Westfalenstadion wurde gerade gebaut, also war eine spannende Zeit. In der Zeit bin ich hier zur Welt gekommen und nach der aktiven Zeit sind wir aber wieder zurückgekehrt nach München.
Würdest du dich nach wie vor so als Sportdirektor, die war zwischen 2009 und 2012, das sind jetzt auch schon wieder zehn Jahre her, aber würdest du dich noch nach wie vor als Mitglied der Bayernfamilie bezeichnen oder gewinnt man da relativ schnell Abstand?
Relativ schnell nicht, weil es war eine extrem intensive Zeit für mich. Und ich habe mir auch danach Zeit genommen, das Ganze aufzuarbeiten, zu verarbeiten. Und Mitglied der Bayernfamilie glaube ich nicht. Ich habe einen Großteil meines Lebens beim FC Bayern verbringen dürfen, als Spieler, Jugend, Profi, Sportdirektor, tolle Zeiten gehabt. Aber wir haben ein gutes Verhältnis, wenn man sich sieht, freundschaftliches Verhältnis, aber auch in gewisser Weise ein neutrales Verhältnis.
Wie ist deine Bayernsozialisation? Du kommst ja aus München, Max. Wie bist du dem FC Bayern begegnet in deiner Jugend, als junger Erwachsener?
Du fühlst mich hier bewusst aufs Glatteis in Dortmund. Ich bin ja nicht gebürtiger Münchner, ich bin eigentlich Franke. Ich hätte eigentlich Clubfan werden müssen, aber das blieb mir erspart. Ich war früher mal Fan dieses Vereins. Aber inzwischen würde ich mich nicht mehr als solcher bezeichnen, zum einen, weil ich journalistisch auf den Verein blicke, und da sollte man nicht mehr zu sehr Fan sein. Und dann auch, weil man schon wirklich ein sehr euphorisierter Bayern-Fan sein muss, um wirklich alles gut zu finden, was dieser Verein macht. Und das bin ich nicht.
Und als du entdeckt hast, dass nicht alles gut an diesem Verein ist, hast du dich entschlossen, über Uli Hoeneß zu schreiben. Du hast ja einen Vorlauf. Du hast einen 17-teiligen Podcast über ihn veröffentlicht, der sehr ausführlich ist. Das sind, glaube ich, auch insgesamt knapp 20 Stunden Material. 30 gesendete Stunden, genau. Und war das von vornherein die Idee, den auszuweiten in diese Biografie?
Nein. Ich wusste am Anfang, als ich damit angefangen habe, noch gar nicht, dass das so ausarten würde. Sonst hätte ich es vielleicht auch nicht gemacht. Es war eine spontane Idee, weil ich Uli Hoeneß als Person faszinierend fand, weil er eben eine dieser wenigen Figuren in Deutschland ist, wo eigentlich jeder eine Meinung hat. Also ich glaube, man könnte eine Straßenumfrage machen, egal in welcher Fußgängerzone. Und kaum jemand würde sagen, wer ist denn überhaupt Uli Hoeneß. Sondern alle hätten sofort irgendeine Meinung. Und gleichzeitig geht das so ganz weit auseinander. Also es gibt die Leute, die ihn bis heute abgöttisch verehren. Und es gibt aber auch die Leute, die ihn richtig abgrundtief nicht mögen. Und das fand ich faszinierend. Und ich war irgendwo so in der Mitte. Ich dachte mir so, ja, weiß ich nicht. Und dann dachte ich, mir könnte ja interessant sein, mal rauszufinden, wie ich über ihn denke, wenn ich mich richtig intensiv mit ihm befasse. Und schwupps, schon vier Jahre später gibt es dieses Buch.
Das ist ja auch keine so einfache Entscheidung, weil es ja schon sechs Biografien zuvor gab. Und hast du herausgefunden bei deinen Recherchen, wie begeistert Uli Hoeneß von diesen Biografien ist? Oder welche Haltung er dazu hat?
Ja gut, also Uli Hoeneß steht ihm erstmal kritisch gegenüber. Er ist aber dabei auch nicht ungerecht. Also man muss da ein bisschen das trennen, was Uli Hoeneß in der Öffentlichkeit über die Biografien sagt und das, was er vielleicht mit den Biografen besprochen hat. Also er hat zum Beispiel mal gesagt, dass all die Biografen nie mit ihm gesprochen hätten. Und das ist nachweislich feit. Das stimmt einfach nicht. Weil das alles Sportjournalisten sind und als Sportjournalist hat man eigentlich automatisch fast schon mit Uli Hoeneß gesprochen, weil er einfach fünf Jahrzehnte in der Öffentlichkeit stand. Also er sieht das kritisch und das ist ja auch sein gutes Recht, denn es ist sein Leben, was da beschrieben wird. Ich glaube allerdings, ich habe keine Rückmeldung zu dieser Biografie und das ist ja auch ganz wichtig zu sagen, es ist keine autorisierte Biografie. Natürlich nicht. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie er darüber denkt, aber ich glaube, er ist schon jemand, der es wertschätzen kann, wenn jemand um Sachlichkeit und Ausgeglichenheit bemüht ist. Und dann wird er bestimmt nicht mit jeder Silbe hier übereinstimmen. Ehrlich gesagt hätte ich aber wahrscheinlich meinen Job auch nicht richtig gemacht, wenn er alles hier zu 100 Prozent unterschreiben würde.
Christian, hast du den Podcast von Max wahrgenommen? Hast du da mal reingehört? Hast du einige Folgen parat? Wie hast du das Werk von ihm empfunden?
Ja, auf längeren Autofahrten. Ich bin normalerweise schwer zu begeistern, für Podcasts einfach vielleicht auch nicht konzentrationsfähig genug, mehr im hohen Alter. Aber Uli Hoeneß ist natürlich für mich im beruflichen Bereich eine sehr prägende und entscheidende Figur. Ich habe sehr viele Facetten von ihm miterlebt. Wie richtig gesagt wird, jeder hat eine Meinung zu ihm. Es wird öffentlich auch sehr viel über ihn gesprochen. Bei diesem Podcast habe ich einfach gemerkt, dass er mich auch fesselt, dass ich sehr interessiert bin an den Recherchen, weil doch sehr viele Menschen befragt wurden, die ihm nahe stehen. Ich finde, dass es insgesamt sehr gut anzuhören war und für mich auch eine Bereicherung, irgendwo nochmal bei so einem Menschen den gesamten Werdegang, Kindheit, Jugend, Fußballspieler und dann entscheidende Personen im deutschen Fußball zu werden. Ich habe mir alle Folgen angehört.
Im Unterschied zu deiner Biografie, die du genannt hast, aus Liebe zum Spiel heißt der Podcast ja über Uli Hoeneß 11 Leben. Wie kam es zu dieser Titelfindung?
Da stecken zwei Überlegungen dahinter. Zum einen war es so, dass wir einen Titel gebraucht haben, wo klar ist, es geht um Fußball und es ist aber ein biografisches Werk, weil es solche Art von Podcasts bisher in Deutschland noch nicht gab. Und da ist eben die Zahl 11 die Fußballzahl und dann ist uns nichts Besseres eingefallen als Leben. Tatsächlich war aber der Podcast dann auch nicht von mir, sondern von anderen beteiligten Personen durchaus darauf ausgelegt, 11 Staffeln zu produzieren. Also es sollte nicht die 11 Leben des Uli Hoeneß sein, das fände ich nämlich albern, der Mann hat ein Leben und das war halt sehr voll. Aber das war ursprünglich mal der Plan, jetzt nach den vielen Jahren Arbeit will sich aber an diesem Plan nicht jeder gleich gerne erinnern. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie das wird. Beim Buch war dann eben klar, dass es einen anderen Titel braucht und dass dann der Titel auch mehr aussagen muss. Elfleben ist bewusst sehr neutral gehalten. Und beim Buch sollte man aber schon, finde ich, schon mit dem Titel den Menschen etwas zum Nachdenken geben. Und dann habe ich wie über viele Dinge sehr lange nachgedacht und hatte sehr viele Ideen. Und am Ende ist es aus Liebe zum Spiel geworden, weil da eine Mehrdeutigkeit drinsteckt. Man kann es verschiedentlich interpretieren. Und weil es aber auch grundsätzlich an den Kern geht, der mich, glaube ich, mit Uli Hoeneß dann doch verbindet, trotz aller Unterschiede. Ich liebe, liebe, liebe Fußball, also das Spiel Fußball. Und ich glaube, auf dieser Ebene bin ich ziemlich nah an Uli Hoeneß, denn so geht es ihm, glaube ich auch.
Wie viele Gesprächspartner hast du ausfindig machen können, die dir auch Rede und Antwort gestanden haben?
Also ich habe mit über 40 Personen gesprochen. Die meisten davon durfte ich auch zitieren. Wer natürlich fährt, ist Christian Nerlinger. Warum?
Können wir heute nachholen.
Jetzt ist das Ding gedruckt, das ist schade.
Da kommt ja bestimmt nur ein zweiter Teil. Er ist 71.
Ist es in der Tat nie zur Kontaktaufnahme gekommen mit Christian?
Eine Anfrage gab es schon, aber dann keine Reaktion. Und dann hatte ich allerdings auch daraus geschlossen, dass ich da nicht weiter nachhaken muss. Das war die Phase, wo du eigentlich kaum Interviews gegeben hast. Oder gar nicht, glaube ich sogar auch. Und ich habe das grundsätzlich bei eigentlich allen Anfragen so gehandhabt, dass ich den Leuten – bis auf Uli Hoeneß – bin ich niemandem so richtig lange nachgelaufen, weil ich finde, jeder hat ein Recht darauf, auch nicht zu sprechen. Und ich hatte dann auch irgendwann das Gefühl, ich habe ja Gesprächspartner gefunden, ansonsten hätte ich da, glaube ich, hartnäckiger sein müssen. Aber ich habe 130 Menschen angefragt, davon sind 40, ein paar und 40 sind dann im Buch gelandet. Und im Podcast, da hatte ich dann das Gefühl, das ist auch okay so.
Das war von dir eine bewusste Entscheidung, Christian, sich dann nicht zu äußern? Oder war dir gar nicht so klar, worauf das Ganze hinausläuft? Was waren deine Beweggründe?
Ja, ich habe lange Zeit gehabt, wo ich es wahnsinnig genossen habe, nach der Bayern München-Zeit aus der Öffentlichkeit komplett raus zu sein. Keine Kameras, keine Analysen von Spielen, keine Rechtfertigungen für Niederlagen, keine Ahnung. Das hat sich sehr lange angehalten. Es hat sich dann ein bisschen aufgeweicht. Es ist immer noch nicht meine große Leidenschaft, aber mit so netten Gastgebern macht man das natürlich. Ich glaube, damals war auch die Steueraffäre gerade noch dominant. Vielleicht habe ich da auch die Angst gehabt, dass es ein bisschen einseitig werden könnte. Das waren wahrscheinlich die zwei Gründe dafür.
Schilder doch mal deine prägnanteste Absage von einem Gesprächspartner, den du dir gerne gewünscht hättest.
Das war Paul Breitner. Insgesamt hat mein Telefonat mit Paul Breitner acht Sekunden gedauert. Das ist tatsächlich sogar in der Verifikation dokumentiert mit einem Handy-Screenshot. Das war die prägnanteste Absage. Es war nicht die überraschendste Absage. Ich habe viele Leute angefragt, bei denen ich schon wusste, jetzt fliegt gleich die Tür zu, aber man muss es ja trotzdem machen. Das ist ja ein Teil der journalistischen Sorgfaltspflicht. Und man hat ja dann doch die Hoffnung, vielleicht bleibt die Tür ja, wenn ich ganz nett frage, doch noch ein bisschen auf. Das war die prägnanteste Absage. Und dann war es generell interessant zu sehen, es gab viele Menschen im näheren Umfeld von Uli Hoeneß, die alle gesagt haben, wenn Uli Hoeneß mitmacht, dann mache ich auch mit. Und am Ende habe ich Uli Hoeneß zum Interview bekommen. Das wussten wir bloß alle beteiligt, nicht inklusive Uli Hoeneß und mir. Deswegen war es dann quasi mit seiner ersten Absage, die auch ein bisschen deutlicher war, sind da wie so mit so einem Luftzug mehrere Türen dann automatisch zugegangen.
Ja, damit ist die Dramaturgie des Abends dahin. Also ich hätte ganz gerne – so entwickelst du ja deinen Podcast. Also es ist ja spannend, du lässt die Hörer teilhaben daran, wie der entsteht. Und du veröffentlichtest Folgen, ohne dass du bereits dieses Interview mit Uli Hoeneß hast. Und am Ende, alle sind gespannt, kriegst du dieses Interview oder nicht? Jetzt hast du es ja gerade verraten. Ich denke, die meisten haben den Podcast auch gehört. Also diese künstliche Spannung brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr aufbauen. Am Ende hast du Uli Hoeneß zum Interview gehabt, da kommen wir nachher nochmal drauf. Hast du dann für die Biografie die Recherche nochmal erweitert, oder war das schon von vornherein, dass dich das da reingoss, dass du das quasi eins zu eins übernehmen konntest?
Na eins zu eins natürlich nicht, ich musste schon nochmal viel daran arbeiten. Ich habe tatsächlich nochmal ein paar Dinge anrecherchiert, wie man so sagt, und habe auch gerade in den früheren Kapiteln auch nochmal neue Passagen geschrieben, die im Podcast nicht gelandet sind. Allerdings muss ich leider sagen, dass die Dinge, in die ich dann auf viel Zeit in die Recherche gesteckt habe, dann alle nicht mehr ins Buch gepasst haben. Also im Nachhinein hätte ich mir das dann sparen können, aber ich neige sowieso dazu, Dinge zu ausführlich zu machen. Hat ja auch wieder über 400 Seiten das Buch, das war durchaus auch nicht von allen Seiten so geplant. Also von meiner Seite aus schon. Beim Verlag gab es da durchaus noch so ein paar Diskussionsgrundlagen für. Also ich habe schon nochmal viel nachrecherchiert, aber tatsächlich musste ich dann auch feststellen, das war aber dann auch beruhigend, dass der Podcast ja auch schon keine Dinge erzählt hat, die man jetzt hätte weglassen können. Also neben halt dem ganzen Handlungsstrang, ob ich ihn zum Interview bekomme, das habe ich natürlich weggelassen. Das sind im Buch zwei Absätze. Das ist ja auch viel weniger spannend. Aber ansonsten habe ich ja auch im Podcast schon eine Vorauswahl getroffen. Und als ich dann das Buch geschrieben habe, habe ich gemerkt, ach, das hat schon alles so Sinn ergeben. Ich dachte auch, ich mache nochmal, ich könnte das noch erzählen und das noch. Und dann, als ich beim Schreiben war, habe ich gemerkt, nee, das Wesentliche ist eigentlich dann doch das, was ich schon mal erzählt habe.
Du gehst sehr chronologisch vor. Du steigst also ein in die Zeit, als Uli Hoeneß noch in Ulm zu Hause war, als er dort Fußball gespielt hat als Jugendspieler. Wir drei haben ihn alle nicht spielen sehen. Ich bin Jahrgang 1969, ich wäre noch der Erste, der es hätte tun können. Aber da war er schon Invalide, als meine Fußballbegeisterung dann losging. Hat dir dein Vater über Uli Hoeneß als Spieler was erzählt? War das mal Thema? Was hat Uli Hoeneß als Spieler ausgemacht?
Ja, es war damals eine andere Zeit. Mein Vater ist von einem kleinen Vorstadtort zum großen FC Bayern, Beckenbauer, Hoeneß. Und es hat da natürlich schon eine klare Klassengesellschaft gegeben. Also da waren die 13, 14 etablierten. Ich glaube, Zebetsch war damals Trainer und hat im gesamten Saisonverlauf 13 Spieler eingesetzt. Also heute unvorstellbar, die haben einfach immer gespielt. Und der Muskelfaser ist wurde auch erst später erfunden. Den hat es damals noch nicht gegeben. Also und ich glaube, das war ja auch in meiner Zeit schon langsam ein bisschen besser. Aber früher natürlich ältere, gestandene Spieler, die haben das die Jungen spüren lassen. Und da ist in den zwölf Monaten, wo er dann da war, inhaltlich, sportlich nicht viel passiert. Aus seiner Sicht jetzt im Nachhinein ein zu früher Wechsel. Nach einem Jahr hätte er einen guten Berater gebraucht, um das zu ändern. Aber im Nachhinein ist man immer schlauer. Und deswegen hat es da eigentlich keine so Proanten gegeben oder Anekdoten aus dem Zusammenleben oder aus der Kabine oder so. Also da ist wenig mehr überliefert worden.
Uli Hoeneß war aber doch dann schon ein sehr forscher junger Spieler, als er zum FC Bayern kam, beziehungsweise noch mal einen Schritt davor. Es ist auch interessant, wie er seine eigene Spielerkarriere in der Jugend schon begleitet hat. Nicht nur, indem er aktiv aufgetreten ist, sondern er machte schon Publicity auch in eigener Sache.
Ja, das war für mich eine der überraschendsten Erkenntnisse über Uli Hoeneß, dass er selbst mal quasi in einem ähnlichen Feld unterwegs war, wie wir nämlich im Sportjournalismus und die Berichte seiner eigenen Spiele geschrieben hat. Ich weiß nicht, soll ich die kurze Passage lesen? Du guckst mich so erwartungsfroh an. Bei euch sehe ich es nicht, weil es so hell ist, aber ihr guckt bestimmt auch alle erwartungsfroh, oder? Dann würde ich eine kurze Passage lesen aus dem ersten Kapitel zu groß für Ulm und der Abschnitt heißt auch Rasender Reporter von Ulm. Wir befinden uns jetzt so in der Phase, wo Uli Hoeneß zum allerersten Mal in nationalen Medien auftaucht, das ist 1969, ist er zum ersten Mal im Kicker zu finden. Und noch öfter liest man jedoch an anderer Stelle von ihm, und das aus einem besonderen Grund. Hoeneß ist Autor seiner eigenen Spielberichte. Peter Bietzer arbeitet damals als Sportredakteur bei der Schwäbischen Donauzeitung. Dort begegnet er dem 15-Jährigen zum ersten Mal. Nach dem Spiel gegen England hat er sich gemeldet. Er kam in die Redaktion mit einem handgeschriebenen Bericht von diesem Großereignis, denn er ging davon aus, dass das die Leute interessiert. Ab diesem Moment schreibt Hoeneß regelmäßig über die Spiele seiner Mannschaften. Er hat die Artikel in einem linierten Schulheft geschrieben und in die Redaktion gebracht, erinnert sich Peter Bietzer. Auch am Sonntagmittag nach Auswärtsspielen, die 30 Kilometer von Ulm entfernt stattgefunden haben. Er kam verschwitzt und abgehetzt mit dem Fahrrad in die Redaktion und hat dann den Spielbericht vorgelegt, in dem natürlich jeder Pass von ihm erwähnt worden ist. Warum hat er auch das noch gemacht? Ging es ihm nur darum, die eigenen Tore zu beschreiben? Bietzer hat eine andere Antwort. Er wollte Geld verdienen. Er hat nicht mal hochgehandelt, von 7 Pfennig pro Zeile auf 9 Pfennig. Pro Artikel bekam er 10 bis 15 DM. Das war viel Geld für einen Schüler. Beim Thema Geld zeigt sich ein Unterschied zwischen Uli Hoeneß und seinen Eltern, der typisch für seine Generation ist. Stimmten die Verkäufe in der elternlichen Metzgerei nicht, strahlte das bis ins Familienleben hinein. Wenn von den 20 vorbestellten Gänsen nur 17 abgeholt worden waren, war das Weihnachtsfest versaut, erzählt Hoeneß später. Doch wie begründet sind die Existenzängste seiner Eltern? Sicher hat die Familie nicht im Überfluss gelebt, aber Ulm geht es schon recht bald nach dem Krieg wirtschaftlich wieder gut. Es sind große Industriebetriebe dort beheimatet, die 1950er und 1960er Jahre des Aufschwungs. Es ist kein Zufall, dass der Bäcker und der Metzger zuerst an den Esisberg ziehen durften. Beide wurden gebraucht für die Versorgung des Viertels und hatten damit ein verlässliches Einkommen. Wenn man es nicht zur Sicherung der eigenen Existenz benötigt, bekommt Geld einen anderen Charakter. Es ist Ausdruck von Erfolg und eine Form der Anerkennung. Der sportliche Ehrgeiz von Hoeneß lässt sich leicht erklären. Er wollte Profifußballer werden und dafür sind Disziplin und hartes Training nötig. Sein finanzieller Ehrgeiz dürfte aber mehr gewesen sein als bloß der Wunsch nach Absicherung. Anders als die Generation seiner Eltern hat Uli Hoeneß nie Sorge haben müssen, von jetzt auf gleich alles zu verlieren. Mit Blick auf seine Jugend erzählt er, dass sein Vater die Wurst lieber Grammweise verkaufte, anstatt Kiloweise an die Kantinen der großen Betriebe in Ulm. Für ihn unverständlich. Wenn es eine Chance auf mehr Gewinn gibt, dann muss man die doch nutzen. Uli Hoeneß wächst in einer Zeit des wirtschaftlichen Rückenwindes auf. Im Zeitraum von 1950 bis 1970 steigt das Bruttoinlandsprodukt pro Einwohner preisbereinigt fast um das Dreifache. Deshalb kann er furchtloser agieren und das mit einem klaren Ziel. Bei ihm war sicher keine Notsituation bestimmen, sondern es ging um Anerkennung. Dass vielleicht doch der Metzgerbub in der Klasse mit den Doktorssöhnchen denkt, er will mehr sein, sagt sein ehemaliger Lehrer Kraft Otto Steinle dazu. Hoeneß entstammt einer Generation, die prägend für das deutsche Wirtschaftsleben werden wird. Dirk Rossmann, Jahrgang 1946, Dieke Brüder-Tönnies, 1952 und 1956, und Götz Werner, 1944 Gründer von DM, sind nur einige Beispiele für Kinder der Nachkriegszeit, die mit Mut zum Risiko Unternehmen aufgebaut haben, die heute eine Rolle spielen und noch immer in Familienhand sind. Allein ihre Firmen haben zusammengerechnet einen Umsatz von 26 Milliarden Euro und rund 115.000 Beschäftigte. Gemeinsam ist ihnen eine Jugend in Zeiten des wirtschaftlichen Aufschwungs sowie ein Ethos der Sparsamkeit, des Ehrgeizes und harter Arbeit, das sie von ihrer Elterngeneration vorgelebt bekommen haben. Im Fall von Hoeneß wird diese Haltung von einem Selbstbewusstsein ergänzt, das nicht untypisch für seine Umgebung ist. Ulm ist eine stolze sowie unabhängige Stadt. Ihr Münster haben sich die Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner selbst gebaut, nicht im Auftrag eines Bischofs oder König. Bei der Planung hatte es Platz für das Doppelte der damaligen Einwohnerzahl. Bis heute ragt zudem der höchste Kirchturm der Welt über Ulm. Fun Facts mit Uli Hoeneß. Die Ulmer sind knorrig, selbstbewusst und haben ihren eigenen Kopf, urteilt Wolfgang Dieterich, der Geschäftsführer Touristik der Stadt ist, weil sie eben nie eine Residenzstadt waren wie München, Karlsruhe oder Stuttgart. Typisch ist dabei das nüchterne, sachliche, bescheidene und auch ein Stück weit pietistische Denken. Wenn sie ins Rathaus kommen, dann gibt es zwar eine Brezel, aber ohne Butter.
Also er war damals schon sehr umtriebig. Er hatte nicht nur sportlichen Ehrgeiz, er wollte Geld verdienen, er wollte vielleicht der Enge dieser Stadt Ulm entkommen. Der schnellste Zugang zu viel Geld war ja dann schon der Profifußball, aber er ist nicht sofort Profi geworden. Er hat ja am Anfang seiner Karriere auch schon etwas rumgetrickst, damit er sein persönliches Ziel – das war die Teilnahme an den Olympischen Spielen 1972 – erreichen kann.
Wie lief das damals ab? Er hat sich dafür entschieden, Amateur zu bleiben, denn nur Amateure durften an den Olympischen Spielen am Fußballturnier teilnehmen. Er war dann tatsächlich angestellt beim FC Bayern und hat dafür ein Gehalt bekommen und war dementsprechend auf dem Papier kein Profi.
Was war er angestellt?
Er selbst sagt als Gärtner, der Verein hat ganz lange gesagt, in der Poststelle, seit 11 Leben sagen sie auch wieder als Gärtner, ist mir aufgefallen. Das war so eine übliche Trickserei für diese Zeit der Bundesliga tatsächlich auch. Wenn man sich anguckt, der Bundesligaskandal zum Beispiel hat ja auch wesentlich mit vorgetäuschten Verträgen zu tun. Und das ist dann schon interessant, dass man da auf der einen Seite einen sehr reglementierten Bereich hat, der DFB da eben sehr streng war und gesagt hat, gewisse Gehälter dürfen nicht überschritten werden und gewisse Statuten müssen erfüllt sein. Und auf der anderen Seite war eine gewisse, nennen wir es mal, Kreativität zu sehen bei den Vereinen, beim Umgehen dieser Statuten. Und eigentlich wussten aber alle Bescheid. Also der Bundesligaskandal in seiner Größe war dann schockierend für die Öffentlichkeit, aber es durfte niemanden im Fußball damals überrascht haben. Und das sehen wir auch in der Karriere von Uli Hoeneß. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie wollen wir das bewerten? Also es wurde gerne, vor allem schon damals in dieser Zeit, Anfang der 70er, wurde immer das Bild gezeigt eines sehr raffgierigen Menschen, der nur aufs Geld aus wäre. Also ich kann das genau an dieser Episode in seiner Karriere ehrlicherweise nicht erkennen. Es ist aber auch durchaus typisch für die Art und Weise, wie damals auch über Geld berichtet wurde, weil eben also diese genannten Menschen zum Beispiel, die jetzt diese großen Familienunternehmen haben, die haben alle in dieser Phase sehr viel Geld verdient und haben eben zum Teil auch Bereiche der Mittelschicht überholt fast schon mit ihrem Reichtum. Und das merkt man glaube ich auch in der Berichterstattung, wie damals auch über jemanden wie Uli Hoeneß gesprochen wurde. Das war jemand sehr Junges, der sehr früh sehr viel Geld hatte, obwohl er Amateur war bis 72. Und das wurde nicht mit Wohlwollen betrachtet, sondern eher mit Misstrauen und vielleicht auch mit der klassischen Neiddebatte, die wir so gerne in Deutschland führen.
Christian, schilderte uns doch mal vielleicht aus deiner eigenen Erfahrung, wie es ist normalerweise, wenn man als junger Spieler in die Mannschaft des FC Bayern kommt. So ein bisschen vergleichbar ist es ja schon, als du Anfang der 90er in die Mannschaft gekommen bist, da gab es auch Lothar Matthäus, es gab Jorginho, es gab Augenthaler, gab es auch noch…
Augenthaler war immer da.
Wie bewegt man sich so am ersten Trainingstag oder in den ersten Wochen in so einer Mannschaft?
Mit großer Demut. Die musst du natürlich so schnell wie möglich ablegen, sonst hast du überhaupt keine Chance. Aber ich weiß, die ersten Trainingseinheiten zum warmmachen, fünf gegen zwei, und ich war tot. Ich war tot, weil ich nur drinnen war und das Tempo zu hoch war. Ich bin mit großen Augen durch die Kabine gegangen. Das war auf einmal schon ein Bayern-Fan, war mit meinem Großvater im Olympiastadion. Wir sind zur Säbener und haben uns Autogramme geholt. Das war mein Leben. Ich habe dann als Jugendlicher auf dem Stadtplan meine Radelroute zur Säbener Straße organisiert und auf einmal bist du Teil des Ganzen, bzw. wir sind Teil des Ganzen. Das sind für mich traumhafte Erinnerungen, dieser Weg aus der eigenen Jugend heraus. Damals gab es eine Phase der Durchlässigkeit, waren ja dann noch Markus Babel, Lidi Hamann und dann auf einmal wirklich für deinen Verein spielen zu dürfen mit diesen Persönlichkeiten. Und Augenthaler jetzt war schon noch der Chef des alten Schlages. Da hast du natürlich wahnsinnig profitiert und war für mich spannend. Ich habe dann nicht mehr mit ihm zusammen gespielt, er war dann Co-Trainer, als ich gespielt habe. Die fünf Jahre bei Bayern München und auch die ersten Momente waren natürlich ein absoluter Traum.
Uli Hoeneß ist ja nicht als einziger namhafter Jung-Nationalspieler bzw. Jugendnationalspieler zum FC Bayern gewechselt, sondern er hatte seinen Kumpel aus der süddeutschen Auswahl mit im Schlepptau. Das war damals Paul Breitner und auch noch den Trainer quasi. Der Jugend-Nationalmannschaftstrainer war damals Udo Lattek, der dann wenig später Bayern-Trainer wurde. Täuscht der Eindruck, dass auf einmal diese drei den Verein, obwohl sie noch Lattek vergleichsweise junger Trainer, die beiden junge Spieler eigentlich den Verein direkt irgendwie übernommen haben?
Ja, also ganz so krass fast nicht. Also zum einen hat Udo Lattek Paul Breitner und Uli Hoeneß davor bewahrt, zu 1860 zu wechseln, denn das war eigentlich tatsächlich schon mit Geschäftsführer Meyerberg ausgemacht von 1860. Und dann hat Udo Lattek sie am Rand eines Jugend-National-Länderspiels zur Seite genommen, hat gesagt, macht man noch nichts, und dann sind sie zusammen dahin. Ich glaube, dass es nicht so war, dass sie von Anfang an den Verein umgekrempelt haben, denn die Wirkkräfte von Präsident Neudecker und Manager Schwan, die waren schon entscheidend immer noch. Also was Schwan und Neudecker gesagt haben, das wurde gemacht. Und wenn Franz Beckenbauer eine Ansage gemacht hat, dann wurde das jetzt auch nicht direkt ignoriert, um es jetzt mal so zu sagen. Vor allem waren Beckenbauer hatte damals schon eine nationale Bekanntheit und auch eine wohlwollende Presse ihm gegenüber, dass das durchaus auch kritisch begleitet wurde, dass da eben mit Hoeneß und Breitner zwei Spieler kamen, wo die Demut eher in Anführungszeichen stand. Die haben die Demut sehr schnell abgelegt, nämlich schon auf der Fahrt nach München. Und beim ersten Training war die Demut dann schon weg. Das ist ein bisschen zu viel, aber im Nachhinein muss man schon sagen, dass sowohl Lattec als auch Breitner und Hoeneß die fehlenden Puzzlestücke waren. Der FC Bayern hatte vorher schon Erfolg. Er hat ja auch schon ein Europapokal gewonnen, 1969. Man hatte auch schon im nationalen Wettbewerb die ersten Erfolge. Aber mit Breitner hatte man eine ganz andere Spieleröffnung und Robustheit in der Verteidigung. Mit Hoeneß hatte man jemanden, der die Geschwindigkeit und die Ausdauer hatte, Gegenspieler müde zu laufen und hatte auch ein gutes Zusammenspiel mit Gerd Müller. Das war tatsächlich das, was den FC Bayern erst national und dann auch international so weit nach vorne gebracht hat, dass man dann ja auch die größten Erfolge feiern konnte, von denen Bayern noch jahrzehntelang gezehrt hat. Die Fans, die man sich in den 70ern aufgebaut hat, waren auch in den 80ern wichtig. Und dann auch Anfang der 90er, als das ja gar nicht so erfolgreich mal war, ausnahmsweise bei den Bayern. Da hatten die schon einen irren Stock an Fans, auch in den neuen Bundesländern. Und ganz viele davon zogen sich zurück auf diese Zeit. Beckenbauer, Müller und dann eben auch Breitner und Hoeneß. Also deswegen, sie waren nicht allein dafür verantwortlich, aber es war vielleicht die wichtige Zeit, die den Grundstein dafür gelegt hat, warum der FC Bayern nie wirklich tief fallen könnte, selbst als man Schulden hatte, selbst als die Steuerfahndung dann vor der Tür stand. Die Bayern hatten immer schon eine Bekanntheit, die ihnen geholfen hat.
Ich habe jetzt in der Vorbereitung noch mal den ersten Sportstudioauftritt von Uli Hoeneß angesehen, damals mit Dieter Kürten. Uli Hoeneß war glaube ich 20 Jahre alt, wenige Wochen beim FC Bayern und wurde danach befragt, welche Spieler er sich denn noch beim FC Bayern vorstellen könnte. Und dann fragte Dieter Kürten noch Ente Lippens vielleicht, der offensichtlich damals im Gespräch war beim FC Bayern. Nö, nö, der nicht. Der Graubowski wird uns gut zu Gesicht stehen. Was glaubst du Christian, würde man heutzutage, wenn ein 20-jähriger Spieler so im Sportstudio auftreten würde und schon die Vereinspolitik mitgestalten würde? Was würde man mit machen?
Sehr schwierig, weil es ja auch mediale Orkanik gibt mittlerweile, die gewaltig sind. Nur muss ich auch sagen, ich habe ja vorher noch mal einen Rundgang gemacht hier durchs Museum und bin dann bei Giovanni Trapattoni stehen geblieben, die Ära Trapattoni. Und da wurde eben lustigerweise auch in dem Beitrag ein junger Spieler gefragt, Alexander Zickler. Er soll doch bitte mal die Taktik von Giovanni Trapattoni beschreiben. Alexander Zickler war damals auch 20, ist aus Dresden gekommen. Er hat gesagt bei euch, also live nachzuhören hier im Museum, das ist ganz einfach, wir führen 1-0 und er wechselt beide Stürme aus. Also auch mutig, weil so ein Haufen Kritik konnte man da raushören. Und vielleicht hat es damals der Uli Hoeneß auch gar nicht so als vereinspolitisches Thema gemeint. Aber was ihn natürlich immer begleitet hat, ist unglaubliche Offenheit, Klarheit, auch wenn du ein Interview mit Uli Hoeneß machst, kriegst du immer Substanz aus. Und natürlich auch Mut, Dinge anzusprechen und eben diese Polarisierung voll zu akzeptieren. Weil, was der Mensch in seinem Leben auf der einen Seite erreicht hat, aber was er auch kritisiert wurde, das ist gewaltig und das zeichnet ihn einfach aus. Und es hat ihn als Jungen ausgezeichnet und es zeichnet ihn heute auch noch aus.
Trotzdem gab es ja dann auch Phasen, als jetzt kleiner Zeitsprung 2013, glaube ich, gibt es ein sehr kritisches Interview von Philipp Lahm über die Vereinspolitik des FC Bayern. 2009 fällt er dann sogar noch in deine Zeit rein. Also, da muss ich ihn fragen. Genau. Da war er sehr empfindlich und hat auch in seiner typischen Art und Weise gesagt, das wird die höchste Geldstrafe, die der FC Bayern jemals über einen Spieler ausgesprochen hat. Was hat ihn daran so gestört, dieses Interview mit Philipp Lahm? Mochte er das nicht, dass Spieler, wie er sich selbst als junger Spieler zur Vereinspolitik geäußert hat, das hat seinen Spielern nicht zugestanden?
Doch, aber wenn die Diskrepanz des persönlichen Austausches zu groß war zu dem, was dann öffentlich kommuniziert wurde, glaube ich, das ist etwas, ich habe den Philipp als absoluten Führungsspieler geschätzt. Immer noch finde ich, dass er beides, das Sportliche und das auch als Kapitän, seine Aufgabe top erfüllt hat. Er war für mich auch in meiner Zeit als Sportdirektor ganz, ganz wichtiger Ansprechpartner. Seine Meinung hat Gewicht gehabt, genauso wie die von Schweinsteiger, Neuer oder Müller. Das waren für mich immer Spieler, wo ich wusste, die Meinung nehme ich wahnsinnig ernst, auch in zukünftigen Entscheidungen. Aber wir waren, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, auch insgesamt in einer etwas schwierigeren und komplexen Situation im Verein. Es stand gerade die Veränderung von Uli Hoeneß zum Aussichtsratchef und Präsidenten an. Also schon ein riesengroßer Einschnitt. Und wenn dann so ein nicht abgesprochenes Interview zum falschen Zeitpunkt kommt, dann muss man sich mit dem Spieler auch mal kritisch auseinandersetzen.
Was mich da, wenn ich kurz darf, interessieren würde, also das mit dem, dass die interne Kommunikation nicht zu öffentlichen gepasst hat, das hat auch Uli Hoeneß dann in einem Interview gesagt, hat gesagt, also wir haben jetzt zum ersten Mal mit Philipp Lahm über diese Themen gesprochen, hätte er mal früher kommen können. Glaubst du denn, es hat auch eine Rolle gespielt, dass Philipp Lahm in dem Interview ziemlich deutlich gesagt hat, dass er glaubt, mit dir als Sportdirektor, und da sei er sich auch mit vielen Spielern einig, könnt ihr jetzt quasi eine neue Art der Kadergestaltung Einzug halten bei Bayern?
Jetzt muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist 2009 passiert, jetzt sind wir 2022.
Du willst nicht sagen, du erinnerst dich nicht mehr.
Ja, aber fragmentartig, den genauen Inhalt, es war schon Kritik, sicherlich zu verspüren, die Gespräche mit dem Philipp, die waren jetzt nicht so, dass wir uns umgehauen hätten oder bekriegt hätten, sondern es waren eigentlich sachliche Gespräche, sachliche Auseinandersetzungen, weil der Philipp immer einer war, der hohe Wertschätzung genossen hat. Ich glaube einfach, dass die Erwartungshaltung von einem Club, und das finde ich auch, um ein vertrauensvolles Verhältnis miteinander aufzubauen, musst du Dinge intern ansprechen und das Gespräch suchen. Und wenn du dann irgendwann mal spürst, es geht nicht mehr weiter, kann man vielleicht diesen Weg wählen. Aber so war es eben das Problem. Wir sehen das heute oftmals in der Trainer-Manager-Situation, wenn ein Trainer meint, der Kader ist nicht gut genug aufgestellt, man spricht, man spricht, man spricht, es passiert nichts, und auf einmal kommt die Bombe öffentlich. Ob das zielführend ist, weiß ich nicht, aber alle Beteiligten sind stark unter Druck und wollen natürlich einen Kader zur Verfügung, der die Qualität besitzt. Aber ich glaube nach wie vor, der Inhalt war es gar nicht so, sondern der Zeitpunkt und dass es eben vorher nicht angesprochen wurde, weil beim Uli Hoeneß eines, als ich angefangen habe, beim FC Bayern als Sportdirektor oder als Spieler, beim FC Bayern als Sportdirektor hat es vier Büros gegeben und die Türen bei Uli Hoeneß waren in beiden Richtungen offen. Zu mir und rechts war der Finanzchef Karl Hopfner, und dann hat er von seinem Platz rübergeschrien, Karl, können wir das machen? Ist das möglich? Der Karl hat gesagt, ja, das können wir machen. Also gut, dann machen wir es. Also war total offene Kommunikation. Und das hat er sich immer gewünscht von Spielern. Und für die Spieler ist er auch immer durchs Feuer gegangen. Und das war, glaube ich, schon der Hauptpunkt, dass da so eine Enttäuschung war. Du schlägst auf einmal die SZ auf und liest dann eine relativ fundamentale Kritik.
Zurück zu seiner Spielerkarriere nochmal. Das hat ihm nicht geschadet, diese öffentlichen Auftritte, sein Vorschuss auftreten auch nicht, sondern ganz im Gegenteil. Uli Hoeneß war mit 22 Jahren Europameister. Er ist Mitglied einer der besten Nationalmannschaften, die als einer der besten Nationalmannschaften aller Zeiten gilt. Das ist diese Mannschaft, die 1972 im Viertelfinale der EM in England gewonnen hat. Er ist Weltmeister. Kann so ein Mensch dann noch normal bleiben? Oder ist seine Entwicklung besonders nachvollziehbar?
Ich kann ja sowieso immer nur über die öffentlichen Personen Uli Hoeneß sprechen. Deswegen normal im Sinne nur auftreten, nach außen. Ich glaube schon, dass Uli Hoeneß ein Beispiel für jemanden ist, so wie wir es heute manchmal auch bei Spielern erleben. Ich glaube, Uli Hoeneß und vielleicht auch Paul Breitner haben schon in einer Echo-Kammer gelebt, als wir alle das Wort Echo-Kammer noch gar nicht kannten. Also das, was wir heute auch erleben, dass das junge Spieler, das kennst du ja als Spielerberater noch viel besser, dass quasi schon 14-Jährigen gesagt wird, Mensch, du bist der Allerbeste und wenn der Trainer dich nicht aufstellt, dann ist der schuld und ist ein riesen Depp und muss weg. Also dass man quasi immer so eine positive Bestätigung bekommt, die nicht per se schlimm ist, die aber vielleicht zu einer verzerrten Wahrnehmung, vielleicht auch Eigenwahrnehmung führen kann. Ich glaube, das hat man bei Uli Hoeneß auch schon sehen können, denn bei aller Kritik, die er auch schon früh erfahren hat, war er sehr gut darin, sich von dieser Kritik zu lösen, um es mal so zu formulieren. Und da hilft es dann natürlich auch, wenn du mit 22 alles gewonnen hast, was zu gewinnen ist, national und mit der Nationalmannschaft. Das ist ja eine völlig irre Karriere und tatsächlich auch unvergleichlich im deutschen Fußball bis jetzt. Es gibt im Männerfußball keine andere Karriere, bei der eben in seinem so jungen Alter schon diese Titel alle da waren. Und vielleicht, das geht jetzt dann so ein bisschen in den Bereich des privaten Hoeneßes rein, deswegen muss man da vorsichtig sein, das ist dann eine Spekulation. Aber vielleicht hat dann eben das Ende seiner Spielerkarriere, das eben auch sehr früh kam und das nicht selbst gewählt war, vielleicht hat das auch tatsächlich diesen Funken gelegt für dieses Feuer, mit dem Uli Hoeneß dann drei Jahrzehnte durchgerauscht ist als Manager, wo man sich auch dachte, Mensch, eigentlich könntest du es doch jetzt gut sein lassen, aber er konnte es eben nie gut sein lassen. Und er konnte es nicht mal nach einem 0-0 beim VfB Stuttgart gut sein lassen, wenn man an der Tabellenführung schon stand, sondern bei Uli Hoeneß musste es immer die perfekte Leistung sein, es musste der erste Platz sein. Und selbst wenn er gesagt hat, nach dem Champions-League 2001, hat er gesagt, Mensch, das ist jetzt der Moment, wo man endlich mal genießen kann. Dann habe ich mit Leuten gesprochen, die damals dabei waren, die haben gesagt, ne, der hat schon damals direkt gesagt, nächste Saison greife mal an, als wir noch den Pokal hochgeproben haben. Also das scheint in ihm angelegt zu sein.
Ich denke einfach, dass viele vergessen, wie erfolgreich er auch als Spieler war. Viele verbinden einfach manchmal auch nur diesen Elfmeter, den er 1976 im MMM-Finale übers Tor geschossen hat, weswegen die Deutschen damals verloren haben gegen die Tschechoslowakei. Aber er hat zumindest die Verantwortung übernommen, und das auch schon sehr früh vorher schon. Bei der WM 74 hat er auch Elfmeter schon geschossen, mit 22. Und als Uli Hoeneß nicht angetreten ist, ist sein gleichaltriger Kollege Paul Breitner im Endspiel. Also eigentlich so Dinge, die man sich heute kaum noch vorstellen könnte. Das zeigt ja so ein bisschen schon auch die Verantwortung, die die Bedeutung, die sie in diesem Kader hatten. Sowohl bei der Nationalmannschaft, auch bei Bayern München.
Ja, das stimmt. Sie hatten diese Bedeutung. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob es heute nicht mehr vorstellbar wäre. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst. Ich weiß nicht, wann Joshua Kimmich angefangen hat, Elfmeter zu schießen zum Beispiel. Aber ich würde sagen, das gibt es immer mal wieder. Dass es eben Spieler gibt, die auch schon so gefestigt in den Mannschaftsgefüge sind, dass sie sagen, ich treffe einen Training, jetzt treffe ich jetzt halt auch.
Das gibt es doch heute auch. Der Elfmeter ist ja praktisch die Querverbindung. Das Entscheidende ist, wie dreht dich als Spieler auf, als junger Spieler? Ich habe es gerade gesagt, mein Naturell war damals Demut, Dankbarkeit und natürlich um den Platz kämpfen. Wenn du so auftrittst wie Uli Hoeneß und Paul Breitner, dann musst du liefern. Und zwar jedes Training und jedes Spiel. Weil die Mitspieler natürlich eben wie schon gesagt nicht alles gut finden. Wie die vorgeprescht sind mit – es gibt ja dieses Bild, wo sie da oberfrierefrei sind. Und dann wildfremde Familien zu sich nach Hause, zum Branchen einladen und so weiter. Und du magst dich in dem Moment angreifbar, wenn du nicht 100 Prozent lieferst. Und das kommt ja auch raus, dass Uli Hoeneß auch als Sportler ein Besessener war im Fitnessbereich. Vollgas gegeben hat und natürlich eben beide ihre Stärken gehabt haben, unterschiedlich. Der eine Athlete, der andere genialer Fußballer. Und das ist heute genauso. Wenn du dich rauslehnst, wenn du stark nach außen lebst, dann musst du sportlich performen. Sonst wirst du zerrissen innerhalb des Clubs der Mannschaft, zumindest kritisiert. Aber ich finde auch bei unseren medialen Entwicklungen, es gibt mittlerweile echt Orkanen. Orkanen, die für mich teilweise durch nichts mehr zu rechtfertigen sind. Und alle springen darauf, in einer Art und Weise, die nicht nachvollziehbar ist. Und dafür verstehe ich Spieler, wenn sie sich ihr Schutzschild bauen und nicht mehr so auftreten wie die Herren Hoeneß und Breitner früher.
Er war rücksichtslos gegen sich selbst auch, allerdings dann auch auf Kosten. Oder hat er damit den Mannschaftserfolg gefährdet? Es heißt, dass er im WM-Finale 74 mit Fieber angetreten ist, auf dem Platz gelaufen ist. Ist das nicht auch ein Unfairness oder ist das einfach dieses Unbedingte, ich will jetzt dabei sein? Wie schätzt du das ein?
Beides. Und je nachdem, wie das Spiel dann läuft, bewerten wir es unterschiedlich. Das Spiel wurde gewonnen, deswegen ist es jetzt eine lustige Anekdote, wenn das Spiel verloren gegangen wäre. Und Uli Hoeneß war derjenige, der nach einer Spielminute den Strafstoß zum 1 zu 0 der Niederländer verursacht hat, hätten die das verloren. Und dann hätte er es vielleicht nicht so freimütig erzählt. Es kam ja von ihm die Info, dass er Fieber hatte und so weiter und die Matratze mehrmals gewendet hat, damit es niemand merkt und den Schlafanzug gewechselt hat. Aber ja, also alles, was du sagst, stimmt. Es ist gleichzeitig egoistisch, es gefährdet den Mannschaftserfolg. Gleichzeitig ist es aber auch sinnbildlich für Uli Hoeneß. Und jetzt im Nachhinein ist es eben dann eine weitere Anekdote seines Lebens. Aber das ist schon – also jetzt ganz vereinfacht gesagt – die Eier muss man auch echt haben.
Er hat es so gesehen teuer bezahlt. Er hat teilweise im unfitten Zustand gespielt. Er hatte eine Knieverletzung und musste länger pausieren. Er hat sich dann aber zu den großen Spielen, sprich Europapokalfinale, immer wieder fit spritzen lassen und hat da seine Gesundheit riskiert und musste deswegen seine Karriere frühzeitig bennen mit 27. Wie sehr zeichnete sich das gegen Ende der Karriere ab, dass er tatsächlich direkt auf einen so verantwortungsvollen Posten zusteuert, wie er das dann gemacht hat, weil er mit 27 direkt Manager von Bayern München wurde?
Dass er Manager wurde, war überhaupt nicht überraschend. Er verletzt sich im Europapokal der Landesmeisterfinale 75 schwer am Knie. Es wird fehl diagnostiziert, es wird nicht operiert. Mit dem ersten Training knickte er um. Der Außenmeniskus wird weggenommen. Ab dann hat er immer Probleme am Innenmeniskus. Jetzt beginnt eine Leidenszeit, die auch für die damalige Zeit nicht so untypisch ist. Er musste sich jeden Donnerstag das Knie punktieren lassen, um am Samstag zu spielen. Das ist aber gleichzeitig so, wenn das mir die Mannschaftskollegen von damals erzählt haben. Dann haben die es jetzt nicht gesagt, das musst du dir mal vorstellen, sondern die haben gesagt, beim Uli war das auch so. Weil damals waren die medizinischen Bedingungen auch andere. Aber deswegen musste er sich schon sehr viel früher mit dem Gedanken ans Danach der Karriere befassen. Und dass er Manager wurde, war dementsprechend nicht überraschend, denn er hat auch Robert Schwan als so eine Art Vorbild gesehen, also den damaligen Manager der Bayern. Und gleichzeitig hat Schwan Hoeneß sehr gerne benutzt, nicht nur um den Geldkoffer durch den Zoll zu tragen, sondern er hat ihm auch viel beigebracht, also bei Hotelbuchungen und so weiter.
Das hat er oft auch mal Uli Hoeneß machen lassen. Und Spieler-Transfers und Sponsoren-Verträge hat er schon vorher eingefädelt.
Genau, und das ist jetzt eben das Interessante. Uli Hoeneß war mehrmals in seinem Leben zur richtigen Zeit, am richtigen Ort. Er ist zum FC Bayern gekommen, als der FC Bayern zwar schon Erfolg hatte und auch schon wichtige Spieler hatte, wie eben Müller, Roth, Beckenbauer, Mayer, aber es war noch Platz für Paul Breitner und Uli Hoeneß. Und gleichzeitig war er am Übergang vom Spieler zum Manager, als der FC Bayern praktischerweise gerade auch einen Manager gesucht hat. Denn Robert Schwan ist mit Franz Beckenbauer in die USA entschwunden, weiter Fembeck, der Geschäftsführer, hat es dann so mitgemacht. Aber es war von Anfang an dann in Ordnung und auch für den Präsident Neudecker. Der hat das dankend angenommen, dass Uli Hoeneß dann gesagt hat, soll ich Paul Breitner zu uns holen? Braucht man einen neuen Sponsor für? Ich mache einfach beides. Und das war die Zeit, wo es gerade nicht mehr so lief sportlich. Da war Neudecker extrem dankbar, dass er auf den Jahreshauptversammlungen, die damals übrigens auch schon turbulent waren, gab es bloß noch keinen Twitter, dass er da eine positive Nachricht hatte. Und dann hat Uli Hoeneß das eben einfach neben seiner Karriere als Spieler gemacht. Heutzutage schwer vorstellbar und hatte auch manchmal so ein bisschen Geschmäckler. Also er hat ja auch schon für den FC Bayern Spieler verpflichtet, als er noch beim ersten FC Nürnberg gespielt hat. Fanden damals auch nicht ganz alle so prall, muss man jetzt sagen, gerade in Nürnberg. Weil die sind dann abgestiegen. Aber er war da im richtigen Moment, am richtigen Ort. Und er hatte aber halt auch die Fähigkeiten, das dann zu tun als Spieler.
Vielleicht wäre das der Zeitpunkt, wo du mal den ersten Arbeitstag vorliest von Uli Hoeneß.
Das können wir doch gerne machen. Und dann möchte ich aber gerne danach von Christian wissen, wie sein erster Arbeitstag war. Der ist nämlich nicht ganz so gut dokumentiert, leider muss man sagen, als der von Uli Hoeneß.
Das war auch kein ganz so epochales Ereignis wie die Amtsübernahme von Uli Hoeneß.
Ja gut, das werden wir ja gleich herausfinden. Also wir befinden uns jetzt im Kapitel 4, Buhmann der Liga. Und wir befinden uns im Mai 1979. Denn im Mai 1979 betritt Uli Hoeneß zum ersten Mal als Manager das Trainingsgelände an der Säbener Straße. Zur Feier des Tages kommt er im SAKU mit einem Notizblock unter dem Arm, nimmt er im fast leeren Büro von Robert Schwan Platz. Dann telefoniert er drei, vier Stunden und fährt nach Hause. Das war's. Seine Sekretärin bittet nach den ersten drei ereignislosen Wochen kündigen zu dürfen. Aber Uli Hoeneß sagt, warten Sie mal ab. Es geht bald los. Gerade weil diese Geschichte so unspektakulär ist, erzählt Hoeneß sie gerne. Sie zeigt, auch ich habe klein angefangen. Und ihr unausgesprochener Teil ist, schaut nur, was daraus geworden ist. Losgelegt hat er aber streng genommen schon vorher. Nicht nur mit dem Transfer von seinem Bruder Dieter zum FC Bayern, den hat er eben eingefädelt, als er noch beim ersten FC Nürnberg Spieler war, sondern von Beginn an widmet sich Uli Hoeneß zudem den wichtigsten Einnahmequellen des Vereins. 85 Prozent des Etats machen damals Zuschauereinnahmen aus. Also verspricht Uli Hoeneß jedem Käufer einer Dauerkarte für die nächste Saison einen von der Mannschaft original signierten Ball. Aber ohne, dass die Spieler daran mitverdienen. Das ist deshalb wichtig, weil es für Uli Hoeneß anders ist. Sein mit Neudecker ausgehandelter Vertrag sieht eine Beteiligung an den Dauerkartenverkäufen vor. Er widmet sich also nicht nur den Einnahmequellen des Vereins, sondern auch seinen eigenen. Hoeneß verdient, die Spieler machen die Arbeit. Das führt zu einigem Unmut, vor allem bei Jupp Kapellmann. Der schimpft öffentlich, woraufhin der Vertrag von Hoeneß modifiziert wird. Kapellmanns Zeit bei Bayern endet kurz darauf, als Hoeneß ihm eine Klausel aus dem Vertrag streicht, die es Kapellmann erlaubt, für sein Medizinstudium Trainingseinheiten zu verpassen. Vor die Entscheidung Studium oder Fußball gestellt, zieht der keine andere Wahl, als zum Lokalrevall in 1860 zu wechseln. Was für ein Schicksal. Kapellmann ist ein meinungsstarker Spieler. Es gibt viele Beobachter, die damals schreiben, Hoeneß ist der zu meinungsstark. Neben den Zuschauereinnahmen versucht Hoeneß noch an weiteren Schrauben zu drehen. Die bisher verlangten Gagen für Freundschaftsspiele sind ihm zu niedrig. Noch vor seinem offiziellen Amtsantritt fliegt er nach Kuwait und kommt mit Plänen zurück, die laut Kicker wie ein Märchen aus 1000 und einer Nacht klingen. Den Winter sollen die Bayern im warmen Scheichtum verbringen, sich dort vorbereiten und zu lukrativen Freundschaftsspielen antreten. Letztlich wird es zu so etwas erst einige Jahre später kommen, aber die Reise zeigt, wie kreativ Hoeneß das Unterfangen der Einnahmenssteigerung angeht. Heute sind wir daran gewöhnt, aber damals wäre der FC Bayern der erste Bundesligis gewesen, der für Geld seine Vorbereitung in die Wüste verlegt. Beim wichtigen Thema der Testspiele versucht Hoeneß, das Beste für alle Beteiligten herauszuhandeln. Er reduziert ihre Zahl und kommt damit den Spielern entgegen. Und er nimmt nur lukrative Angebote an, damit auch die Einnahmenseite stimmt. Ab jetzt gilt ein ökonomisches Leistungsprinzip. Stimmen die Zahlen in Tabelle und Konto, genießen die Spieler Freiheiten. Gerät eines von beiden in Schieflage, nimmt Hoeneß sie in die Pflicht. Als es gut läuft in der Liga, verspricht Hoeneß, weniger Freundschaftsspieler anzusetzen. Kurz darauf verlieren die Bayern überraschend und haben schlechte Zuschauerzahlen, weshalb es doch wieder zu einem Privatspiel geht, wenn auch auf ungewöhnliche Art und Weise. Das waren Tagesausflüge, das kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen, berichtet Bernd Dürmberger, Spieler von damals. Wir sind morgens nach Tunesien geflogen, haben nachmittags Fußball gespielt und sind abends wieder zurückgeflogen mit dem Learjet. Für die Spieler sei das schon eine Belastung gewesen, sagt er. 100.000 Mark nimmt der FC Bayern durch solche Trips innerhalb eines Tages ein. Hoeneß sind die Zahlen wichtig, er ist jedoch noch Spieler genug, um zu wissen, dass für sportlichen Erfolg investiert werden muss. So erklärt er zum Beispiel angesprochen auf den Aufenthalt in einem Luxushotel während einer USA-Reise. Bei den Strapazen ist das Plaza gerade gut genug. Zudem fördert er die Erholung der Mannschaft mit dem Physiotherapeuten Stanislav Brablec, den er von seinem Ausflug zum 1. FC Nürnberg mitgebracht hat. Bayern zahlt für ihn sogar eine Ablösesumme. Ich war praktisch der erste Masseur-Transfer der Bundesliga, sagt Brablec. Bei den Bayern stößt er nicht nur auf ein aufgestocktes medizinisches Personal – der junge Dr. Müller-Wolfhardt hilft jetzt mit, hatte übrigens damals schon dieselbe Frisur – sondern zusätzlich auf die Bereitschaft, ihm die beste Technik zur Verfügung zu stellen. Die SZ staunt in einem Artikel über den Massageraum der Bayern, der eher einem Forschungskomplex im Max-Planck-Institut ähnelt. Zudem fließt in die Nachwuchsarbeit jetzt mehr Geld. Der Etat der Nachwuchsmannschaft erhöht sich um 100.000 auf 450.000 Mark. Der Mann, der als Nachwuchsstar Weltmeister wurde und dessen Karriere nach Fehldiagnosen und einem strapaziösen Spielbetrieb viel zu früh endete, schickt das Geld des Vereins zuerst in diese Sachen – Regeneration, medizinisches Personal und Nachwuchs.
Vielen Dank. Bevor wir vom ersten Arbeitstag erfahren, den du als Sportdirektor dann hattest, vielleicht auch nochmal zurück zu deiner Spielerkarriere, Christian, du hast dann Uli Hoeneß als Manager erlebt. Wie war deine, hast du noch Erinnerungen an deine erste Begegnung, wie du in sein Büro gekommen bist? Du hast ja schließlich dann auch einen Profivertrag aushandeln müssen. Was war er für ein Verhandlungspartner?
Das war damals der erste Profivertrag. Er war sehr schnell und für mich überwältigend. Das ist das, was das Intensive ist. Er war bei allen Themen der Mannschaft dabei. Jedes Trainingslager. Wir waren erst ganz am Anfang in einem Bauernhof in Dietrams Zell. Jeden Freitag war er dabei. Er ist mit der Mannschaft zu jedem Teil der Mannschaft. Er war bei allen Terminen dabei. Zu den Unterschriften mussten wir Trikots und Bälle unterschreiben, aber im hohen Maße. Da war er aber nicht mehr dran beteiligt, da ging es wirklich um das FC Bayern. Wir durften jeden Monat mindestens 5000 Autogrammkarten unterschreiben, weil er den Fans Autogrammkartensätze des FC Bayern kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen will. Ich habe auch gesagt, da können ja praktisch Menschen 20-mal, 30-mal hinschreiben. Ja, aber das müssen wir gewährleisten. Auch das Thema öffentliches Training ist ja immer weniger geworden, aber er hat bis zum Schluss gekämpft wie ein geisteskranker öffentlich. Die Fan-Nähe war ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Punkt. Was ich mitnehme aus der Spielerzeit, unglaubliche Nähe. Im Prinzip das, was du mit Freundschaftsspielen gerade beschrieben hast, haben wir erlebt mit Kartenspielen, weil er war ein wahnsinnig gern gesehener Gast am Scharfkufftisch, weil er meistens verloren hat. Nach Niederlagen war er relativ zornig. Er hat gesagt, dieser Scheißdreck, der muss jetzt mal aufhören. Wir müssen uns aufs Fußball konzentrieren nach dem nächsten Sieg. Meine Herren, ich bin bereit. Es war tatsächlich so, dass das Glück des FC Bayern und die Siege des FC Bayern auch sein Glück waren. Natürlich kommt es super rüber, wenn du nicht so ein distanzierter Geschäftsmann bist, sondern ein Mensch, den man irgendwann nach Monaten oder Jahren wirklich kennt, der sehr eng dran ist und seine Emotionen in dieser Art und Weise auslebt.
Und sein Geld. Also Mehmet Scholl hat mal gesagt, er hat ganze Familienurlauber gemacht, wo er dann gesagt hat, danke Uli Hoeneß, hast du mit deinem Schafkopfspiel nach Siegen finanziert.
Es war ja auch ein Physiotherapeut am Tisch, Fredi Binder, der war ein sehr, sehr begabter Kartenspieler. Aber natürlich nicht in der Gehaltsklasse wie die Spieler oder Uli Hoeneß. Und auf den Rückreisen war Uli Hoeneß manchmal eben etwas müde und hat auch in großen Spielen, als er großer Pot in der Mitte war, Fehler gemacht. Und ich war immer einer der Kiebitze, hat zugeschaut und hat dann immer beim Fredi Binder die Halsschlagader. Denen hat sie natürlich nichts sagen, trauen, aber es hat gearbeitet in ihm. Und wenn er wirklich gekonnt hätte, wäre ich ihm an die Gurgel gegangen. Aber ja, so war das, es war dann immer gute Atmosphäre und hat viel Freude bereitet.
Trotzdem noch mal nachgefragt, Christian, es ist ja die Zeit auch noch so, als du Profi wurdest, litten ja viele junge Spieler auch unter den Managern der Bundesliga. Ich glaube, also meine These ist zumindest, dass es diesen Beruf des Spielerberaters, Vermittlers, dass der in die Welt des Fußballs gekommen ist, liegt auch so ein bisschen an dem Fußballgeschäft selbst, weil es in der damaligen Zeit Usus war, jüngere Spieler doch sehr klein zu halten, künstlich klein zu halten, vielleicht sogar auch mit falschen Versprechungen zu locken. Wie hast du Uli Hoeneß als junger Spieler, als Verhandlungspartner, als jemand, der mit dir Verträge ausgehandelt empfunden hat?
Es hat zwei Situationen im Prinzip gegeben. Das war die erste Unterschrift vom Jugendspieler zum Profi, wo du happy bist, wo du Teil des großen FC Bayern wirst, wo ich mich wahnsinnig fair behandelt fühle und wertschätzend. Dann kommt die Entwicklung, wo sich die Situation im Fußball massiv verändert. Die Vereine müssen etwas Kontrolle aus der Hand geben, nämlich mit dem Bosman-Urteil. Die Internationalisierung. Du kannst so viele ausländische Spieler verpflichten, wie du willst. Die Ablösesummen fallen zum Ende eines Vertrages. Das hat schon die Verhältnisse etwas verschoben. Man hat als Spieler auf einmal Einblicke bekommen in Möglichkeiten, die du vorher nicht unbedingt hattest. Ich bin ja dann mit 25 Jahren und es war ja nicht nur ich, es war auch Didi Hamann und Markus Babbel. Wir waren eigentlich Stammspieler beim FC Bayern, die anderen beiden sogar Nationalspieler. Es ist sehr ungewöhnlich, dass du dann in den FC Bayern verlässt. Es war eben eine andere Situation, wo ich glaube, dass der Club auch mal eine Phase hatte und eine Denkweise, wir sind kein Münchner Verein mehr, wir sind ein Weltverein. Wir wollen jetzt auch in diese internationale Schiene gehen. Dann hat man sich da eben getrennt. Das waren dann unterschiedliche Verhandlungen, die waren auch relativ kurz, war sehr klar. Für mich war dann einfach so das Gefühl, der Junge aus den eigenen Reihen zu sein und deswegen auch einen Schritt mal machen zu müssen. Das ist glaube ich auch nachvollziehbar. Genau, das war dann die zweite Thematik.
In deinem Buch ist nachzulesen, Max, dass Uli Hoeneß über den Abgang von Christian Nerlinger gesagt hat, das wäre seine bis dahin größte Enttäuschung gewesen. Warum hat er das gesagt?
Na ja, weil es genau so war, wie es Christian jetzt gerade beschrieben hat. Weil er da einen Stammspieler, der aus der Jugendmannschaft des FC Bayern sich zu den Profis hochgespielt hat, gegen den FC Bayern entschieden hat. Das gab es damals sehr selten und so wie es ich gelesen hatte, hat es auch damit zu tun, dass du damals noch nicht so häufig Nationalspieler warst.
Nullmal.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht den Fehler machen, gar nicht, aber ja, genau. Und danach hat es ja geklappt. Das zieht sich aber tatsächlich so ein bisschen durch das Wirken von Uli Hoeneß. Das kann man ja auch gut nachvollziehen. Für ihn zählt halt der FC Bayern und nur der FC Bayern. Und wenn sich dann jemand gegen den FC Bayern entscheidet und dann vielleicht sogar noch glaubt, er würde einen Aufstieg machen, was es ja in der Welt von Uli Hoeneß gar nicht gibt. Beim FC Bayern geht es nur runter. Aber es gab ja Spieler wie zum Beispiel Michael Balak. Da war es ganz ähnlich, dass Michael Balak gute Gründe gesehen hat, den FC Bayern zu verlassen. Und Uli Hoeneß kann in seiner Welt keinen davon, glaube ich, zählen lassen. Zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit. Ich glaube, wahrscheinlich, wenn man mit ihm da im Zweiergespräch darüber reden würde, wäre er da noch mal ein bisschen anders. Und da war tatsächlich dein Wechsel damals so ein Marke. Das war eben auch die Zeit, in der der BVB auch durchaus finanziell den FC Bayern den Rang abgelaufen hatte.
Ich war Stammspieler bei Bayern München und ich war ablösefrei. Und es ist gerade losgegangen mit der Internationalisierung. Und dann habe ich Erfahrungen gesammelt, weil wir jetzt gerade über die Berater gesprochen haben. Ich war halt alleine mit meinem Vater noch. Und wir sind von Luciano Moggi eingeladen worden nach Juventus Turin. Und da habe ich wirklich gedacht, aus welchem Film seid ihr entsprungen? Das ist Wahnsinn. Das waren Vertragsverhandlungen, die waren unglaublich, wo du gesagt hast, hey, was passiert hier außerhalb der Grenzen Deutschlands? Ich kannte ja nur den FC Bayern. Und natürlich hätte ich jemanden gebraucht und mein Vater auch. Der sagt, hey, okay, das läuft so, wir filtern das. Und dann werden Optionen besprochen. Der Schritt nach Dortmund war dann für mich so, dass ich gesagt habe, okay, ich werde hier noch als Jugendspieler wahrgenommen. Ich hatte unter Otto Rehagel, der bekanntlich auf Spieler steht, die jenseits der 30 waren. Ich war 23, Single. Der steht ja auch auf verheiratete Spieler mit ordentlichem Privatnummer. Trotzdem habe ich Stammspieler geworden. Franz Beckenbauer übernimmt. Ich hatte noch in Barcelona gespielt, vor 110.000 gewonnen. Bei Otto Stammspieler geworden. Wir sind Zweite in der Liga und im Endspiel. Nachdem wir Barcelona – Otto Rehagel wird gekündigt, rausgeschmissen. Es sind noch zwei Bundesligaspieltage und zwei Endspiele. Und ich spiele null Sekunden.
Das war das UEFA Cup-Finale 1996.
Das war für mich, das war 1996 so ein Moment, wo ich mir gedacht habe, okay, in welche Richtung will der FC Bayern gehen? Wir haben tolle Momente gehabt, wir haben auch Momente gehabt, wo Jugendspieler wirklich den Durchbruch geschafft haben. Aber wo geht es jetzt hin? Da hatte ich vom Feeling her kein so gutes Gefühl. Da ist es losgegangen. Das heißt, es war schon ein Prozess, der mich dann zu der Überzeugung gebracht hat, jetzt muss ich mal einen Schritt raus machen.
Ich muss zwei Nachfragen stellen. Zum einen will ich genau wissen, was in Italien passiert ist. Und zweitens, nachdem du jetzt vorhin schon gesagt hast, du hast es so genossen, dann mal nicht in der Öffentlichkeit zu stehen, auf einer Skala von fantastisch bis ausgezeichnet, wie geil war es dann, vom FC Hollywood wegzukommen?
Beim FC Hollywood habe ich mich ja dann auch als Spieler schon sehr rausgehalten. Die Spieler hatten dann ja auch untereinander noch Sitzung. Ich habe gesagt, du kannst eigentlich nicht mehr hören. Hab dann auch nicht mehr teilgenommen. Wenn man es heute wirklich in meine Tiefe geht, ist es wirklich zum Kaputtlachen, was da teilweise abgelaufen ist. Bei Juventus Turin war es so, dass ich einen Anruf bekommen habe und ein Herr zu mir sagt, könnten Sie sich vorstellen, zu Juventus Turin zu wechseln? Ja, Juventus Turin ist schon ein spannender Club. Wer sind denn Sie? Da sage ich, aha, das ist ja interessant. Aber, sagt er, ich kann morgen bei Ihnen sein. Wir fahren zum Flughafen München. Die Maschine von Anjeli steht bereit. Wir fliegen hin, Sie treffen Moggi am Flughafen und wieder zurück. Da haben wir gesagt, das können wir riskieren. Wir sind dann hingeflogen durch die Flughafengänge in so einem Raum. Da sitzt Luciano Moggi in der Mitte. Rechts vereinsligende Betteger und links jemand, der pausenlose Notizen gemacht hat. Dann haben wir geredet und Moggi sagt, wir wollen das. Ich mache es ein bisschen verkürzt, weil es war wirklich wie aus dem Film. Zack, Haus, Gehalt. Dann geht der Schriftführer kurz raus, kommt wieder zurück. Dann habe ich den Zettel italienisch, Linie drunter, Christian Nerlinger. Ich sage zu meinem Vater, ich glaube, die wollen das wir jetzt unterschreiben. War aber alles auf italienisch. Dann habe ich zu Moggi gesagt, Herr Moggi, das ist jetzt wie ein weißes Blatt Papier. Meine Anwälte können Ihnen das vorlesen. Die können übersetzen. Dann haben wir gesagt, leider können wir das jetzt nicht machen. Dann nimmt er das Papier, zerreißt es und sagt, Mr. Nerlinger, we are not God, but we are Juventus Turin. Und dann sind wir heimgeflogen und dann war es für mich sehr angenehm, mit Dr. Gerd Niebam und Michael Maier zu reden.
Offensichtlich waren das dann ja unter Uli Hoeneß noch ganz seriöse, gemäßigte Verhandlungen. Trotzdem, um auch seine Zeit als Manager mal zu beurteilen, blicken wir mal auf seine Transferaktivität. Jetzt habe ich gerade, wo du Otto Areagel erwähnt hast, was ich mich immer gefragt habe, wie konnte man ihn zu dem Zeitpunkt verpflichten, weil er eigentlich ein Urwerderaner war und eigentlich schon über seinen Zenit hinaus war. Also ich habe so diese Transferpolitik, ich habe das eben im Vorgespräch vielleicht, ich will das erklären, wie ich das meine. Ich fand die Transferpolitik von Bayern München zu Wahlen uninspiriert. Ich will damit sagen, man ist immer irgendwo hingegangen, ach ja, dieser Trainer hat ja Erfolg gehabt mit Werder Bremen und jetzt ist ja logisch, er kommt zu uns. Wir schwächen die eine Mannschaft, die uns ein bisschen Konkurrenz macht, neben die zwei, drei besten Spieler, das zieht sich so, hat man sich bei Karlsruhe bedient mit drei, vier Spielern, bei Leverkusen mit Zebro, Roberto Balak und Lucio, bis hin dann schließlich, als Götze und Lewandowski hier von Borussia weggelotst worden sind. Ist das so ein Muster bei den Transfers oder war das tatsächlich intelligente Transferpolitik?
Willst du etwa sagen, Philipp Lahm hätte etwa Recht gehabt, dass der FC Bayern manchmal Dinge tut, ohne eine dahinterstehende Philosophie zu haben?
Ja, zum Beispiel Philipp Lahm hätte man ja ganz einfach auch – Hermann Gerland sagt immer, er muss ihn anbieten wie sauer Bier. Selbst im eigenen Verein wollte ihn ja damals keiner. Gut, er war noch sehr jung, schließlich hat dann Felix Magath sich seiner erbarmt und ihn zum VfB Stuttgart geholt. Aber auch diese – also der Erhegel ist ein Beispiel. Es gab 2008, das war kurz vor deiner Zeit, gab es die – ich weiß nicht, inwiefern du da schon über wir es warst, Christian, man konnte Klinsmann holen oder man konnte auch Jürgen Klopp holen. Also Klinsmann war dann – wer war da für wen? Das ist ja dann auch ein…
Rummenigge war pro Klinsmann und Hoeneß pro Klopp. Also ich würde auch im Nachhinein so wählen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber nee, es soll schon so gewesen sein, also gibt es mehrere Quellen zu.
Genau.
Aber das ist immer die Frage – ich meine, Transferpolitik ist natürlich ein Riesenthema beim FC Bayern. Du suchst in der ganzen Welt im Prinzip die Nadel im Heuhaufen, von der du überzeugt bist, es macht dich besser. Und ich finde, dass der FC Bayern – auch wenn man ein bisschen länger zurückdenkt schon – auch mit Vicente Lissarazu, der ja auch bei euch in der Elftes Jahrzehnts aufgelistet ist, immer mal wieder versucht hat, natürlich auch im Ausland Mark Hughes und Mackinelli und so tätig zu sein – aber natürlich, als Verein willst du Spieler, die zünden. Und mit einem gewissen Maß an Verlässlichkeit. Und wenn du sie vor der Haustür beobachtest, plus meistens spielen sie in erfolgreichen Mannschaften, dann kann man es so interpretieren, dass man schwächt. Man hat Ottmar Hitzfeldt auch von Borussia Dortmund gehört, der hat einen überragenden Job da gemacht. Und du willst beim FC Bayern natürlich die Top-Leute haben, weil du den Anspruch hast, und das ist das Versuchen, andere Klubs zu kopieren, fällt aber schwer, dieses unbedingte Siegergehen und Weltuntergang, wenn du Zweiter wirst. Das ist in diesem Club verankert und ich glaube, das ist wirklich durch das Wirken von Uli Hoeneß einfach über Jahrzehnte so drinnen in dem Club und das kannst du schwer kopieren. Ich persönlich hätte mir auch zu meiner Zeit gewünscht, dass wir die Akademie so stärken, dass du regelmäßig Zulauf hast aus den eigenen Reihen, gestandene Spieler, auch Geld in die Hand nimmst, die in der Bundesliga spielen und natürlich punktuell, so wie wir das mit Arjen Robben gemacht haben, diese Top-Spieler aus dem Ausland. Aber es ist einfach nicht so einfach, wenn du auch in Scouting-Sitzungen bist, wenn du mit Leuten sprichst. Es geht ja um die sportlichen Fähigkeiten, aber du brauchst schon auch so das Gefühl, den Spieler, den du holst, er hat die Persönlichkeit, hier wirklich jedes Spiel gewinnen zu müssen. Der Beckenbauer, Franz hat mal gesagt, Trainer beim FC Bayern, es ist der schönste Job auf der Welt. Du musst nur jedes Spiel gewinnen. Und ich habe das gesagt, das hat er jetzt nicht ernst gemeint. Weil das gibt es nicht, dass du jedes Spiel gewinnst. Aber es stimmt, wenn du ein Spiel nicht gewinnst, geht die Welt relativ runter, dann wird der Finger in die Wunde gelegt und deswegen brauchst du auch bestimmte Persönlichkeiten, wo du halt hoffst, dass sie auch von der Persönlichkeitsstruktur geeignet sind.
Und ich glaube, das hat noch einen weiteren Aspekt, wenn ich das ergänzen darf. Ich glaube, gerade in der Anfangsphase von Uli Hoeneß als Manager, eben 79, 80, 81, 82, ist es sehr interessant, dass vor allem Spieler verpflichtet wurden, mit denen entweder Uli Hoeneß noch zusammengespielt hat oder Paul Breitner. Also, Scouting funktionierte damals noch anders, es gab es nämlich in dem Fall noch nicht. Und natürlich waren dann auch die besten Spieler der Konkurrenz mit dabei und ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt gar kein Aspekt war, dass Uli Hoeneß sich gedacht hat, na ist er vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, wenn er dann auch nicht mehr da spielt und vielleicht auch bei uns spielt. Dann gibt es natürlich Kalle de Halle als das Beispiel eines Spielers, der eben bei Borussia Mönchengladbach sehr wichtig war, zu Bayern gekommen ist und kaum gespielt hat. Also das ist Hand in Hand gegangen, aber ich glaube, das hatte gerade in der Anfangsphase noch eher damit zu tun, dass Uli Hoeneß sehr lange in seiner Karriere bei Spielertransfers erstmal auf sein eigenes Bauchgefühl hören wollte und das vielleicht auch guten Gründen, weil damals gab es noch keine Datenbanken, damals gab es noch nicht dieses Scouting-Netzwerk, wie wir es jetzt haben und später hat sich das verändert und das ist dann quasi das zweite Element, was das erklärt, warum der FC Bayern am liebsten erstmal die Bundesliga leer kauft. Das war, dass man so 2001, 2002 dann sich entschieden hat, man möchte im Grunde als Ziel haben, die besten deutschen Spieler sollen beim FC Bayern spielen und dann hat man eben einen Michael Ballack schon sehr früh verpflichtet, einen Sebastian Deißler früh verpflichtet mit allen Nebengeschichten, die es dazu noch gibt, die stehen auch alle im Buch. Und auch deshalb hat sich das dann so manifestiert, dass es irgendwann so war, dass so ein bisschen so ein Bundesliga-Best-of war, dieses Team. Und gleichzeitig versteht man aber auch die Spielerseite, weil es halt ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt sehr schwierig war, mit anderen Teams Meister zu werden. Und da hat der FC Bayern natürlich einen Vorteil.
Welche Spieler würdest du in der 30-jährigen Manager-Tätigkeit von Uli Hoeneß als die wichtigsten Transfers bezeichnen?
Also er sagt immer Lerby, weil das eine gute Geschichte ist.
Was ist an der so spannend?
Naja, bei Lerby war es damals so, dass der FC Bayern noch verschuldet war.
Und Lerby war dänischer Nationalspieler.
Genau, und hat damals in den Niederlanden gespielt. Und der FC Bayern war damals so hoch verschuldet, weil man hatte so eine kleine Steuergeschichte und musste noch ein paar Sachen nachzahlen. Das soll ja manchmal vorgekommen sein im Fußball, haben die Bayern noch nicht exklusiv. Und da war es dann tatsächlich die Frage, können man sich das überhaupt noch leisten? Und dann hat der Verwaltungsbeirat getagt, ein Gremium beim FC Bayern, das eigentlich eher so ein Networking-Gremium ist. Eigentlich haben sie streng nach Satzung gar nicht Entscheidungsbefugnis, aber damals war es so, dass man gewisse Dinge nicht gegen diesen Verwaltungsbeirat entscheiden wollte. Und der Verwaltungsbeirat hat dann gesagt, na komm, auf die zwei Millionen-Demake kommt es jetzt auch nicht mehr an. Und dann haben sie Lerby geholt, obwohl der damalige Trainer, mit dem man dann Lerby besichtigt hat, noch mal ein letztes Spiel über ihn dann eigentlich gar nicht haben wollte. Aber das war dann so ein Alleingang der beiden Präsidenten Scherer und Uli Hoeneß gemeinsam. Das ist das, was er sagt. Es ist sehr schwierig, das auf einen Spieler herunterzubrechen. Ich glaube, dass die entscheidende Phase für Bayern tatsächlich war, dass man nach einer sehr turbulenten ersten Hälfte der 90er in der zweiten Hälfte der 90er dann auch wieder sportlichen Erfolg hatte. Also wirtschaftlich waren sie immer erfolgreich, aber Anfang der 90er waren die lustigste Phase für alle diejenigen, die es nicht mit dem FC Bayern hatten, weil da ist sehr viel schief gegangen. Und dass man dann den Turnaround geschafft hat und mit Ottmar Hitzfeld, der aber jetzt leider kein Spieler ist, sonst hätte ich nämlich gesagt, Ottmar Hitzfeld war der wichtigste Transfer. Ich glaube, das war entscheidend, dass man das da geschafft hat und wahrscheinlich muss man dann tatsächlich Stefan Elfenberg nennen. Denn Ottmar Hitzfeld war damals der Legende nach, das ist jetzt nur aus einer Quelle überliefert, hat Ottmar Hitzfeld erzählt, war er Golfen mit Beckenbauer und Hoeneß und die haben ihn gefragt, ja wen hättest du gern so, wenn du jetzt bei uns anfängst, wer der Steffen, wer der Elfenberg war. Und Hitzfeld hat halt so gesagt, na klar, Elfenberg ist nicht schlecht. Und dann hat Franz Beckenbauer das noch an Loch 3 klargemacht, hat Elfenberg angerufen und dann war das durch.
Hast du, an welchem Loch hast du die Transfers dann nachher eingestielt, Christian, als du in Amt und Höhen warst? Ich wollte jetzt noch mal nach einer anderen Person fragen, mit der du selbst zusammengespielt hast, Lothar Matthäus, auch einer der wichtigsten Transfers, die der FC Bayern hier getätigt hat.
Klar, Lothar war außergewöhnlich. Ich habe ja in der ersten Phase nicht mit ihm zusammengespielt, aber als er dann als Weltmeister aus Mailand zurückgekommen ist und war ein genialer Fußballspieler, natürlich in einer anderen Welt gelebt, war wirklich ein Weltstar, aber immer einer, der eben dieses Alt- und Jungspieler gar nicht hatte, sondern der zu einem hingekommen ist, Tipps gegeben hat, offen war. Also war unglaublich angenehm, auch nach den Wahnsinnserfolgen, die er hatte.
Mehmet Scholl sagt ja, dass Lothar der beste Spieler, mit dem er jede zusammengespielt hat. Jetzt, wo ich Mehmet erwähne, ein Gesicht des FC Bayern, über zehn, 15 Jahre beinahe. Der kommt aber, den hattest du nicht als Gesprächspartner gewinnen können?
Nee, auch Mehmet Scholl ist glaube ich zu nah an Uli Hoeneß dran, als dass er mit mir hätte sprechen wollen. Wie man tatsächlich noch nennen muss, also Matthäus ist natürlich völlig richtig und ich glaube, man darf Oliver Kahn nicht vergessen, denn – und das könnte man vielleicht sogar jetzt auch aktuell sehen – die Torhüterposition war immer schon extrem wichtig beim FC Bayern, weil du immer schon, ich sag mal, besondere Torhüter haben musstest, die mit dieser Situation beim FC Bayern im Tor stehen zu müssen und eben in der Regel wenig zu tun zu haben und dann aber, wenn man ein Tor kassiert, auch wirklich der größte Depp zu sein. Damit muss man zurechtkommen und da war tatsächlich Oliver Kahn auch extrem wichtig, weil das auch so eine Phase beendet hat, in der die Torhüterposition immer wieder wechselnd besetzt war und Kahn war ja dann die Konstante, die dann eben vom KSC kommend bis ins Jahr 2008 hinein bei Bayern im Tor stand.
Dann könnte man auch Manuel Neuer dann, gerade in dieser Tradition auch erwähnen, da hat er sich gegen die eigenen Fans durchgesetzt. Was sagen denn die Fans, habt ihr das heute zu der Verpflichtung von Manuel Neuer? Also es gibt diese Geschichte, dass die Ultras, waren es die Ultras, die diese Cornuja-Plakate hochgehalten haben, also die sich vehement dagegen ausgesprochen haben, dass Manuel Neuer zum FC Bayern wechselt damals. Aber danach wurden es, glaube ich, zehnmal Deutsche Meister und zweimal Champions-League-Siege. Also so schlecht war der Transfer dann nicht von Manuel Neuer. Wie beurteilt ihr das heute, dass sich die Fans damals so gegen ihn aufgelehnt haben, was ja den Hintergrund hatte, dass Manuel Neuer ultramitglied quasi in Schalke war? Und das war der Hauptgrund für die Ablehnung?
Also man muss das nicht gut finden, aber wenn man sich mit der Fan-Kultur auskennt, dann ist das ein völlig valider Grund, jemanden nicht gut zu finden. Und ich kenne keinen bei der Schickaria, der Manuel Neuer jetzt toll findet, nur weil er zehn Meisterschaften gewonnen hat. Man kann das natürlich, wenn man dem nicht so nahe ist, dann gibt es ganz viele Gründe, das jetzt wiederum auch ein bisschen kindisch zu finden. Aber so funktioniert halt Ultra-Kultur, der gehört halt zum anderen Lager. Und Manuel Neuer hat das ja auch verstanden. Das ist das Interessante an dieser Diskussion, dass Uli Hoeneß sich da natürlich wahnsinnig darüber aufgeregt hat. Und auch in den Medien wurden natürlich da auch die Fans für kritisiert. Denn es ist ja auch tatsächlich objektiv betrachtet schwierig, sich auf einen Spieler und ja auch einen Menschen einzuschießen. Aber Manuel Neuer hat das immer verstanden. Und die Ultras der Bayern wussten genau, was sie da tun. Denn in der Welt, in der die beiden sich bewegt haben, also Manuel Neuer dann irgendwann nicht mehr, war das eben das normale Verhalten. Deswegen muss man das dann vielleicht auch im Nachhinein nicht überbewerten.
Er ist ja glücklich geworden. Ja, ich verstehe das, wenn man sagt, man kritisiert das. Ich war live dabei. Bei dem ganzen Prozess war ein sehr aufwändiger Transfer. Das war sehr fair, auch kostspielig, aber alle im Club waren der Meinung, wir haben die nächsten zehn, 15 Jahre die Nummer eins mit einer Ausstrahlung, mit Fähigkeiten, außergewöhnlich. Wir waren alle einer Meinung. Der Trainer damals, van Gaal, hat da ein bisschen gespalten. Aber von der Vereinsführung waren wir uns klar. Da muss ich sagen, dass das Kritik hervorruft, dass das Unmut hervorruft, total verstanden. Aber ich war beim Warnmachen hinter dem Tor. Wenn dann von eigenen Fans mehr oder weniger Morddrohungen kommen, kurz vor dem Spiel, Beschimpfungen kurz vor dem Spiel in einer Art und Weise, da werden natürlich Grenzen gewaltig überschritten. Und auch im Trainingslager am Gardasee, wo wir geöffnet hatten für die Fans, wüste Beschimpfungen auf dem Weg vom Bus zum Bus. Da sage ich, ich verstehe den Unmut der Fans, der Ultras, aber gewisse Grenzen wurden überschritten. Und wie Manuel Neuer damit umgegangen ist, das war brutal. Also eine Stärke im tagtäglichen Umgang, eine Leistungsfähigkeit. Das war für mich in den jungen Jahren von so einem Menschen schon sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, aber hast du natürlich völlig recht. Diese Grenzen wurden überschritten und das ist nicht gut. Das ist auch nicht zu erklären tatsächlich, aber da stößt man dann auch auf taube Ohren, habe ich festgestellt. Hat ja dann interessanterweise auch Uli Hoeneß betroffen. Also sowohl diese neue Verpflichtung, als auch dann später, als er rauskam, dass man 1860 mit einem Darlehen ausgeholfen hat. Das hat ja bis zum damaligen Zeitpunkt zu der größten Unmutbekundung von aktiver Fanszene gegen Uli Hoeneß gesorgt, mit wirklich auch geschmacklosen Transparenten. Wir alle können uns erklären, warum da auch immer die Worte gewählt werden, die gewählt werden. Aber auch das muss man nicht gut finden an der Ultrakultur. Und das ist interessant, weil sich damit nämlich an der Person Manuel Neuer letztlich so einen Bruch oder einen Riss nachvollziehen lässt, den es vorher schon gab, der sich aber daran dann erstmals öffentlich auch so richtig manifestiert hat, nämlich dem zwischen der aktiven Fanszene des FC Bayern und im Grunde dem Rest des Vereins, die eben schon nicht erst ab diesem Zeitpunkt schon früher viele Dinge kritisch gesehen haben, die ja auch heute dem Verein viel kritischer gegenüber stehen, die ganz viele Dinge nicht gut finden. Und das hat sich damals mit Korn Neuer manifestiert und wurde auch nie wieder gekittet.
Hat Uli Hoeneß diese Bewegung oder die Macht der Fans unterschätzt? Oder hat er vielleicht überhaupt ein Verhältnis zu Fans, das nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist?
Das weiß ich nicht. Dafür bin ich zu selten mit dabei gewesen, wenn er tatsächlich mit Fans zusammensaß. Tatsächlich ist es natürlich schon so, dass jede organisierte Gruppe – das kann man auch hier in Dortmund sehen und das kann man auf Schalke sehen und überall, wo es eben aktive Fanszene gibt, die sich auch ihre eigene Meinung nicht nehmen lassen – jede organisierte Gruppe ist erstmal für die Verantwortlichen von Vereinen ein Problem. Denn die können, obwohl sie in einer Minderheit sind, sehr laut artikulieren. Und die Ultras sind ja auch sehr geübt darin, das auch so zu tun, dass es dann in den Medien landet. Also daher kommt ja zum Beispiel das grenzüberstreitende von Plakaten. Denn ansonsten berichten Medien nicht drüber. Es ist auch ein bisschen schuld des Journalismus, aber das führt jetzt ein bisschen zu weit. Aber deswegen, das war natürlich den Verantwortlichen unheimlich, weil auch die aktive Fanszene, die haben ja eine ganz interessante Zwitterrolle. Sie sind einerseits die größten Kritiker des Systems, in dem sie selbst teilsehen. Und gleichzeitig sind sie aber der Akteur, der auch dafür sorgt, dass dieses ganze System am Laufen bleibt. Denn klar, Fußball kann man auch als Geisterspiel spielen und Fußball kann man auch in Wolfsburg spielen. Aber wenn du es verkaufen willst, dann brauchst du eben Fan-Kultur und dann brauchst du eine aktive Fanszene. Und das glaube ich weiß letztlich auch Uli Hoeneß. Ich kann aber auch verstehen, da das ja auch eine Jugendkultur ist, da fühle ich mich wie der älteste Sack, wenn ich mich mit Ultras auseinandersetze, weil ich eben jetzt auch schon 37 bin und es ist auch eine Jugendkultur, die auch Jugendkultur bleiben soll. Es ist auch wichtig, dass es die ist, aber dass die im Fremd ist, das finde ich jetzt auch, also das würde ich ihm nicht zum Vorwurf machen, aber es ist definitiv so.
Man ist in der Position des Verantwortlichen mit vielen Menschen konfrontiert, mit vielen Bewegungen konfrontiert. Wie konntest du dich auf deinen Job als Sportdirektor vorbereiten? War da Uli Hoeneß für dich ein Lehrmeister? Hat er dich mal zur Seite genommen? Hat er gesagt, pass auf Christian, wir machen das hier so und so? Oder wurdest du mehr oder weniger? Du warst ein Jahr Teammanager zuvor und bist dann quasi auf diese Position des Sportdirektors gekommen. Gab es für dich da so eine Lehrphase? Konntest du viel mitnehmen? Hat Uli Hoeneß dir geholfen oder hast du abgeschaut, wie lief das damals ab?
Er hat gewaltig geholfen, aber am Anfang wusste er, glaube ich, nicht so recht, wie er das alles einschätzen soll. Mit Jürgen Klinsmann kamen ja Veränderungen und wir hatten dann, ja, hat er sich rumgesprochen, dass ich nach der aktiven Zeit eben so ein Studium der internationalen BWL machte, also so ein bisschen versucht habe, den Blick zu erweitern und es ist irgendwie ganz gut angekommen. Und dann hat es ihm geheißen, ja, wir brauchen Teammanagement, ein Teammanager, der sich um alle Themen, die die Mannschaft betreffen, kümmert. Das ging dann auch recht schnell, das Gespräch mit Hoeneß. So richtig vorstellen, glaube ich, konnte er sich das nicht. Hatte so eine Ahnung und ist den Weg mitgegangen, was das für eine Veränderung ist, insgesamt im Club, auch so wie das Jürgen Klinsmann dann eingeführt hat, nach dem Nationalmannschaftsmodell. Für mich war das natürlich ein super Eintritt, weil ich den Verein, wo ich lange Zeit raus war, das war 2008, 1998 bin ich gegangen, wieder mit allen Abteilungen, also Vermarktung, Sponsoring, Medienbereich, Reiseplanung, eng an den Spielern dran, richtig den Verein wieder neu kennengelernt habe und mir der Job wahnsinnig Spaß gemacht hat. Ich dann auch sonntags natürlich bei der zweiten Mannschaft war und dazu geschaut, U19-Spieler angeschaut habe und dann hat Hoeneß halt mitbekommen, dass ich nicht einen Dienst nach Vorschrift mache, sondern glaube, er hat gesehen, dass da eine gewisse Begeisterung da ist und nach zwei Monaten ist er am Tisch gestanden. Wir waren ja in so einem Großraumbüro, aber ich war alleine und dann sagte er, meine Nachfolge ist noch nicht geregelt. Hab ich. Gib Gas. Uli Hoeneß war ja sehr viel mehr als der Sportmanager. Er hatte die ganze Marke FC Bayern, wirtschaftlich, Vermarktung. Und es war dann der Zeitpunkt gekommen, das aufzuteilen und dann ging es hin und her und natürlich wurde dann bekannt, dass irgendwie Hoeneß an andere Positionen einnimmt und haben sich natürlich 100.000 Leute irgendwo beworben und es wurden viele Gespräche geführt und am Abend vor der entscheidenden Aufsichtsratssitzung – ich habe nie nachgefragt. Du wie gar nicht. Sondern immer ihn. Hab meinen Job gemacht und dann ist die Aufsichtsratssitzung, an der ich nicht teilgenommen habe, und er sagte, also wir machen das jetzt. Du wirst Sportdirektor, drei Jahre und das ist dein Gehalt. Und zu dieser Eingebührungsphase, ich wusste natürlich, was es für mich bedeutet, FC Bayern Sportdirektor. Die Eingebührungsphase war schon dieses Teammanagement, wo er auch angefangen hat, mich da schon mitzunehmen. Transfergespräche, Einblicke, wenn er Vorträge gehalten hat, hat er mitgenommen. Und sehr, sehr intensiv natürlich in dieser Übergangsphase. Und da war totales Vertrauen, totale Offenheit und ein gleichzeitig aber professioneller Umgang auch, wo ich schon die Zeit bekommen habe, einfach den Job zu lernen, zu wissen, was es bedeutet, diesen Job von FC Bayern zu machen. Das war eigentlich sehr früh, schon in der Team-Management-Zeit, aber dann natürlich auch in der Anfangsphase als Sportdirektor.
Da kommen wir zu einer kritischen – ja, du bist jetzt auch sofort dran. Ich wollte kurz den kritischen Abschnitt deines Podcasts nochmal in Erinnerung rufen. Du stellst die These auf, beziehungsweise es wurde dir zugetragen, dass es nicht unerheblich gewesen ist, dass Christian am Tegernsee öfter in der Poker- oder Schafskopfrunde aktiv war und deswegen auch gute Karten im Kampf um diesen Manager-Posten, um den Sportdirektor-Posten hatte. Was ist da dran?
Ja, das muss man jetzt aufklären. Das stimmt nämlich nicht so, hat mir ein gewisser Christian Nerlinger erzählt. Du hast nicht im Badehaus am Tegernsee Karten gespielt.
Ich habe dir, weil ich deinen Podcast wirklich sehr gut recherchiert gefunden habe, und ich ihn eigentlich als deine Tonalität, wie du erzählst, bin ich im Auto gesessen, habe es eigentlich als angenehm empfunden. Auf einmal kommt dieser Gastjournalist und sagt, ja, beim FC Bayern gibt es ja eine mafiöse Struktur. Man muss aus dem Umfeld von Uli Hoeneß sein, um einen Posten zu bekommen. Hier in diesem Gartenhäuschen sitzt immer der Nerlinger und spielt Poker mit dem Hoeneß. Ich habe in meinem ganzen Leben noch nie Poker gespielt. Auch nicht im Gartenhaus von Uli Hoeneß am Tegernsee. Aber das bedeutet eben nicht, dass da falsch recherchiert wurde, sondern das wollte ich dir dann einfach auch – ich glaube, ich habe dir eine SMS oder eine E-Mail geschrieben, weil ich deine Leistung als Gesamtwerkseher sehr zu schätzen wusste. Und da wollte ich dich einfach freundlich darauf hinweisen.
Das tut mir auch leid, dass das falsch ist.
Kein Weltuntergang.
Aber was mich jetzt interessiert ist, nachdem ich ja jetzt hier nicht Uli Hoeneß sitzen habe, aber jemand, der den Job von Uli Hoeneß gemacht hat, was war denn das Nervigste an diesem Job?
Ich war ja schon relativ realitätsbezogen. Und wenn du auf Uli Hoeneß folgst, dann wissen sie, was sie getan haben. Otto Reha hat immer als Spieler gesagt, wenn sie beim FC Bayern einen Vertrag unterschrieben haben, dann wissen sie, was sie getan haben. Und genauso war es da auch bei mir. Ich habe versucht, meine Vorstellungen voll umzusetzen. Das waren zum Beispiel Stärkungen der eigenen Akademie. Wenn ich die Mannschaft zum Schluss sehe, wie sie ausgeschaut hat, kann ich mich 100 Prozent damit identifizieren. Aber natürlich, wenn du in so einen Konstrukt, in so eine Übergangssituation reinkommst. Ich möchte es jetzt gar nicht als nervig beschreiben. Aber alle mussten ihre neue Rolle lernen. Uli Hoeneß als Aufsichtsrat, als Präsident, offiziell nicht mehr im operativen Geschäft. Karl-Heinz Rummenigge als CEO, der dann nicht mehr den täglichen Ansprechpartner hat. Für mich war es klar, dass es vielleicht kein Job für die Ewigkeit wird. Dass du, wenn du als erster einer Figur wie Uli Hoeneß nachfolgst, auch ein Ende geben wirst. Aber natürlich habe ich immer Vollgas gegeben und für meine Vorstellungen gekämpft. Es hat dann auch riesige Auseinandersetzungen gegeben, gerade als Fangal kam und den Laden umgekrempelt hat. Da haben wir beide uns nie gescheut, sondern mit offenem Visier gekämpft. Das muss ich auch im Nachhinein sagen, es war sehr anstrengend, weil es ist bei Uli Hoeneß die Liebe zum Spiel, aber tatsächlich auch die Liebe zum FC Bayern. Da ist alles, alles untergeordnet und wenn du beim FC Bayern dann eine verantwortungsvolle Position hast, dann wird wahnsinnig viel verlangt und teilweise eben auch in Phasen, wo es nicht so läuft, kommt auch dieser Schuss Emotionalität rein. Und es war natürlich teilweise wahnsinnig anstrengend, aber ich habe auch Erlebnisse gehabt, für die ich ewig dankbar sein werde, in diesem Club gearbeitet zu haben, in dieser Konstellation mit Rummenigge, mit einem Hoeneß, der auf eine andere Position geht. Und es hat ja auch etwas gedauert, bis sie, finde ich jetzt aus meiner Sicht, diesen Übergang wirklich geschafft haben. Also bei allen Startschwierigkeiten, die Hasan Salihamidzic hatte, wirkt es für mich jetzt schon so, dass sie einen gefunden haben, der sportliche Stärke übernimmt und Entscheidungsträger ist zusammen mit Oliver Kahn. Das ging jetzt im ersten Schuss nicht. Mit Matthias Sammer ging es dann irgendwie auch nur eine gewisse Zeit. Dann war mal die Position gar nicht besetzt. Und jetzt wirkt es so für mich, dass dieser Übergang gelungen ist.
Aber warum ist denn das so, dass, wenn der FC Bayern jemanden entlässt, dass so oft noch etwas hinterhergerufen werden muss? Was nicht ist, danke für deine Arbeit, war echt mega, aber leider hat es nicht gepasst. Bei dir war es ja auch so, dass dann Monate schon, nachdem der Wechsel zu Matthias Sammer vollzogen war, und alles war quasi schon geregelt, und dann, sagt Uli Hoeneß nochmal dem Spiegel, das war ja alles schon im März, hatten wir das schon beschlossen, und wir hätten es ansonsten später gemacht. Und es ist ja dir gegenüber dann doch eine Form der Respektlosigkeit, finde ich, das so offen zu legen. Warum tut sich der FC Bayern so schwer damit, Menschen gehen zu lassen und dann trotzdem dabei noch ein freundliches Gesicht zu wahren?
Also wenn du solche Entscheidungen triffst, und beim FC Bayern hat es ja immer Richtungswechsel gegeben. Also nach Hitzfeld kam Magath, weil die Spieler vielleicht zu wenig trainiert haben. Nach Magath kam Klinsmann, weil Innovationen gefragt sind. Nach Klinsmann kam van Gaal, der es ja straff geführt hat. Ich glaube einfach, dass er auf dieser Position eine Veränderung wollte. Und Matthias Sammer, bestens bekannt hier, Feuerkopf, auch in seinem öffentlichen Auftreten emotionaler. Das ist eine Bauchentscheidung gewesen, wo er überzeugt war, das muss man jetzt machen. Und wenn du so eine Entscheidung triffst, musst du sie ja irgendwie begründen. Ich finde, dass es respektvoll gelaufen ist. Ich finde, wir hatten nach dieser Chelsea-Niederlage Auseinandersetzungen, die ich diese Woche mein ganzes Leben lang nicht vergessen werde.
Was ist da passiert?
Das bleibt unter Verschluss. Es war auf jeden Fall sehr emotional, die Aufarbeitung. Aber nichtsdestotrotz haben wir immer eine Basis gefunden, uns in die Augen zu schauen. Und drei, vier Wochen danach, als alles zu Ende, sind wir auch zu essen gegangen und haben ein sehr sauberes, sehr respektvolles Gespräch gehabt. Und alles, was er auch öffentlich über mich gesagt hat, habe ich nicht zu empfunden. Dass es ein Nachtreten war oder dass es – ich habe den Bericht jetzt nicht ganz so im Kopf, aber wenn es wirklich unter die Gürtellinie gegangen wäre, wäre es mir aufgefallen. Also ich finde, es ist emotional zur Sache gegangen und es war natürlich ein Cut. Aber Nachtreten jetzt bei mir, das kann ich nicht nachempfinden.
Und auch zehn Jahre nach dem Finale daheim kannst du uns nicht sagen, was in den Tagen danach passiert ist. Wie viel ging es um die Elfmeterschützen?
Na, es war eine breite Palette von Punkten, die wir besprochen haben. Es war natürlich eine Situation im Club. Wir haben die Anzahl der Finalteilnahmen schon eklatant erhöht. Ich finde, wir waren in Madrid mit der Mannschaft gegen Mourinho und Inter Mailand noch nicht so weit als Mannschaft. Aber in diesem Finale waren wir in einer Art und Weise überlegen, wo du sagst, das gibt es wahrscheinlich kein zweites Mal, 20 zu 1 Torschüsse in der regulären Spielzeit schon 11 Meter verschossen. Es waren im Postpalast 750 Gäste geladen und du verlierst dieses Spiel. Da ist einfach sehr, sehr viel zusammengebrochen und da ist dann auch ein Schuss Emotionalität erlaubt. Und die Dortmunder waren auch schuld, weil die haben uns im DFB-Pokalfinale zwei Wochen vorher da geschlagen.
Genau, da habe ich mit Philipp Lahm darüber gesprochen. Er meinte, das wäre dieses Pokalfinale, was ich übrigens noch viel krasser finde in dieser ganzen Alters, was dann das nachher das beim FC Bayern alles provoziert hat. Die Bayern waren 2012, muss man sagen, in dem Finale klar unterlegen. Beziehungsweise der BVB hat einen ganz anderen Fußball gespielt, den man hier so noch gar nicht kannte, dieses Gegenpressing, dieses hohe Anlaufen. Man merkte, dass da taktisch unheimlich viel auseinander lag und dass im Prinzip der BVB dann schon zum zweiten Mal einerseits den Titel geholt hat, die Meisterschaft, und dann den Pokalsieg. Aber Philipp Lahm hat gesagt, es wäre alles gar nicht so schlimm gewesen, wenn ihr eine Woche später dieses Finale der ORM gewonnen hättet.
Wir hatten ja ein super Halbfinale gegen Real Madrid, auch im Elfmeterschießen weitergekommen. Aber irgendwie dieses DFB-Pokalfinale hat etwas im Kopf gemacht. Du bist in der Meisterschaft hinten dran gewesen, Pokalfinale. Und wir haben Chelsea auseinandergenommen. Es war unvorstellbar. Wir machen das Tor in der 78. und dann kommt dieses 1-1. Und da war dann der Moment, wo ich irgendwie gespürt habe oder mir die Frage gestellt habe, wer glaubt jetzt noch zu 100%, wirklich zu 100%, nicht zu 99%, sondern zu 100%, wir gewinnen das Spiel. Und das hat sich dann im Elfmeterschießen wiedergespiegelt, als auf einmal Spieler, die im Bernabeu hingegangen sind, das Ding reingehauen haben, zu Hause zurückgezogen haben. Und wir hatten Mühe, das zu ordnen. Wo du dann einfach sagst, da ist einfach etwas passiert.
In Max Buch steht, dass du auch damit beschäftigt warst, die Elfmeterschützen auszusuchen. Was ich doch einigermaßen überraschend finde. Normalerweise macht das doch der Trainer.
Es ist Traineraufgabe, die Schützen zu bestimmen. Ich glaube, dass das Thema einfach etwas unterschätzt wurde, weil es mehr oder weniger klar war, nachdem wir auch gegen Real Madrid im Halbfinale durch Elfmeterschießen weitergekommen waren. Aber es war dann doch etwas turbulenter und wahnsinnig überraschend, muss ich sagen. Wahnsinnig überraschend, dieser Moment. Ja, und ein einschneider Moment.
Hat man dann Verständnis dafür, wenn Spieler zurücktreten und sagen, ich bin jetzt nicht in der Verfassung? Oder wie argumentiert man da, wenn du Elfmeterschützen suchst?
Du wünschst natürlich, dass die Spieler mit breiter Brust und Selbstvertrauen sagen, ich schieße das Ding. Weil im Champions League-Finale oder WM-Finale der Weg, wer den Weg schon mal beschritten hat, von der Mittellinie bis zum Elfmeterpunkt, der ist verdammt lang. Und das Tor wird auf einmal so klein, der Torwart wird auf einmal so riesig. Und da ist die Anzahl sehr, sehr gering gewesen. Und dann gesagt auf einmal dann Manuel Neuer, dann schieße ich. Also das sind schon Drucksituationen und Stresssituationen, die vielleicht eben unterschätzt wurden, weil wir bis dato ja nie Probleme hatten.
Aber um nochmal nachzuhaken, wurde dir das zur Last gelegt? Hast du vielleicht die falschen Schützen ausgesucht?
Ich habe sie ja nicht ausgewählt, das war immer noch der Jupp. Ich war involviert, aber nochmal, ich glaube Aufstellung grundsätzlich. Auch wenn man mit dem Trainer diskutiert, Auswahl der Elfmeterschützen. Wen wechselst du ein, wen wechselst du aus? Das ist Trainer-Tätigkeit und Inhalt. Also ich habe da nicht die Schützen ausgewählt. Ich war nur auch sehr überrascht, dass es eben so schwer gefallen ist, welche zu finden.
Toni Groß ist zum Beispiel nicht angetreten, obwohl man ihn ja als prädestinierten Elfmeterschützen so sehen würde. Ist das vielleicht auch ein Grund, warum man Toni Groß hat gehen lassen? Spielt das eine Rolle, war man dann nicht mehr so überzeugt?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, würde ich aber ehrlich gesagt nicht glauben. Gerade beim Thema Elfmeter hat Uli Hoeneß eine größere Toleranz als viele andere Menschen. Denn er hat eben einfach diesen einen 76er-Elfmeter verschossen. Und er hat ja auch bei der WM 74 im Halbfinale gegen Broden Elfmeter verschossen. Da hätte es ja auch schon zu Ende sein können. Da hat ihn Gerhard Müller letztlich noch gerettet, dass man überhaupt ins Finale eingezogen ist. Also das vermute ich jetzt nicht, ohne dass ich es weiß. Ich glaube, dass bei Toni Kroos andere Dinge eine Rolle gespielt haben. Was man gerüchteweise hört, hat das immer mit dem Gehalt zu tun. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so einfach ist. Interessant ist allerdings, dass das tatsächlich so eine Weggabelung letztlich beim FC Bayern war. Weil da hatte man einen Spieler, der schneller als viele andere den Pep Guardiola-Fußball verstanden hat, der sehr früh alles mit einem Kontakt gespielt hat, mit der Präzision, die Pep Guardiola sich gewünscht hat. Und ich glaube, das war einer der Transfers zusammen vielleicht mit dem nicht zustande gekommenen Neymar-Transfer, der dann wiederum Pep Guardiola gezeigt hat, ich bin hier bei einem Club, wo ich eben nicht alles entscheiden kann, denn da gibt es eben einen Rummenige, einen Hoeneß, die mitreden wollen. Und deswegen hat er einen Spieler verloren, den ich – er hat es ja auch relativ deutlich durchblicken lassen, Pep Guardiola hätte ihn nicht gehen lassen. Und das ist ja das Interessante, das hast du ja auch erlebt. Du sagst, der Übergang ist jetzt geschafft, dass jetzt mit Hasan Salihamidzic jemand diesen Posten ausfüllt. Und ich kann das nicht lösen von dem Fakt, dass Rummenige und Hoeneß zum ersten Mal seit wenigen Jahren eben nicht mehr die dominante Rolle in der Öffentlichkeit spielen. Und auch nach dem, was ich höre, im Klub zwar immer noch Positionen einnehmen, aber es ist eben nicht mehr so, früher war es so, dass man von den unteren Hierarchien, wenn man sich früh überlegen musste, gehe ich jetzt zum Team Rummenige oder gehe ich zum Team Hoeneß mit meinem Anliegen. Wie ist es denn, wenn man zwischen diesen beiden arbeiten muss, wie es ja bei dir war?
Wie ich es gesagt habe, sehr herausfordernd, weil ich finde, sie sind Beides Figuren des Weltfußballs mit außergewöhnlichen Charisma, mit außergewöhnlichen Leistungen, aber trotzdem grundverschieden. Es war ja nicht immer Einigkeit zwischen den beiden. Wenn du dann Medienchef des FC Bayern oder für Sportliche verantwortlich bist, hast du natürlich teilweise Probleme gehabt, weil es eine andere Struktur war. Es waren einfach zwei sehr, sehr starke Pole, die, wenn es hart auf hart ging, immer für den FC Bayern gegangen sind, aber im Tagesgeschäft eben doch oft unterschiedlicher Meinung. Und dann ist es, glaube ich, einfacher in einen Verein oder Unternehmen zu kommen, wo du sagst, ok, klare Struktur, es gibt hier eine übergeordnete Instanz. Ich glaube, dass Oliver Kahn zu jedem Moment Zeit gehabt hätte, beim FC Bayern eine verantwortungsvolle Position zu übernehmen. Aber dass er natürlich auch von seinem ganzen Werdegang in einer anderen Position ist und war als ich, aber einfach auf den Moment gewartet hat, der für ihn jetzt der ideale Einstiegsmoment ist. Ich glaube, den hat er gefunden und das hat er aus meiner Sicht sehr bravourös gemacht.
Noch mal zurück zum Tegernsee. Stichwort, wo wird Politik gemacht? Das war ja nicht nur an derselben Straße, sondern auch wenn du da nicht zum Kartenspielen warst, ist aber doch…
Im Grillen war ich oft eingeladen.
Aber der Tegernsee oder das Domizil von Uli Hoeneß gilt ja schon so ein bisschen auch als Auffangbecken für Spieler, die Sorgen mit sich rumgetragen haben. Es wird ja kolportiert, dass Franck Ribéry da teilweise eingezogen sei. Wie wichtig ist dieses… Vielleicht die Frage an dich, Christian. Was spielte der Tegernsee, das Königreich von Uli Hoeneß im täglichen Schein für eine Rolle? Ist es tatsächlich so, wie man sich das kolportiert wird, dass Spieler dort hingereist sind und dort wieder in die richtige Spur gebracht wurden?
Es war vorher auch so, als er in Ottobrunnen gelebt hat. Es war einfach immer die Tür offen. Ich habe das als Spieler nie so in Anspruch genommen, aber für mich mein prägendes Beispiel, diese Nähe, dieses Dasein für einen Spieler, wenn er Probleme hat, war, als ich hier bei Borussia Dortmund bei einem Konkurrenten war und mir im Jahr 2000 einen Kreuzbandriss zugezogen habe. Das war ein sehr schwerer Moment. Für mich war es Einschlag, Tränen und – kurzzeitig zumindest – Niedergeschlagenheit. Ich bin dann zu meinen Eltern nach Hause und auf einmal klingelt bei uns das Privatelefon der Sekretärin von Uli Hoeneß. Mein Vater sagt, dass er Hoeneß sprechen möchte. Und er sagt, pass auf, Christian, ein Kreuzbandriss ist überhaupt kein Problem. Wir organisieren das jetzt. Du gehst zum Müller Wohlfahrt. Wir schicken dich nach Colorado zum Statman. Und dann spielst du in fünf Monaten wieder. Das war so seine Art, nicht zu mitleiden, sondern zu sagen, lösungsorientiert. Und das werde ich nie vergessen, weil auf der einen Seite sagt er öffentlich, es war eine riesen Enttäuschung, dass ich gegangen bin. Auf der anderen Seite ruft er dich an und hilft dir beim Kreuzbandriss. Das sind natürlich Momente, die du nie vergisst. Es gibt ja immer wieder Verletzungen, es gibt Spieler, die in Schieflagen geraten, in Probleme und da kannst du dich auf ihn verlassen. Das ist einfach so. Und das findet sehr oft eben auch nicht nur im Büro statt, sondern auch in privaten Begebenheiten, wo du dich auch frei und wohlfühlst. Das ist in seiner DNA drinnen, bei allem, was er als Geschäftsmann leistet, diese Nähe und auch da zu sein für Spieler und Wegbegleiter. Und das – klar, Lars Lunde ist öffentlich, das eine oder andere wird öffentlich, aber das meiste ist nicht öffentlich. Und ich glaube, das ist auch das, was ihn auszeichnet und wo ihm viele mit Dankbarkeit verbunden sind.
Er war sich in der Öffentlichkeit nie zu schade oder bis heute nicht als Reizfigur aufzutreten. Er hat sich mit vielen angelegt. Willy Lemke ist ein lebenslanger Rivale. Christoph Daum, all die Geschichten. Was meinst du? Aber er war auch dann immer versöhnlich dann irgendwo ein Stück weiter. Vielleicht nicht so in der Öffentlichkeit, aber es gibt so dann immer Ereignisse, wo er dann gesagt hat, komm jetzt lass mal gut sein. Brauchte er das, dieses Auftreten als Reizfigur? Ist das eine strategische Entscheidung, so aufzutreten?
Nein, strategisch ist das nicht. Aber auch das ist die Liebe zum Spiel. Uli Hoeneß macht, glaube ich, aus sehr vielen Dingen einen Wettkampf. Ich weiß nicht, ob aus allen Dingen, weil dazu kenne ich ihn zu wenig, aber aus vielen Dingen macht er einen Wettkampf und auch bei der öffentlichen Meinungsbildung, um es mal so zu sagen. Das ist für ihn ein Feld, da soll es krachen. Da kennt er auch genau seine Rhetorik und das, was Journalisten brauchen. Deswegen fand ich das eben so interessant, dass er selbst mal, wenn auch natürlich im Rahmen, wie man halt so als 15-Jähriger schreibt, aber er war eben auch mal journalistisch tätig, auch aus seinen Fußballbüchern. Ich weiß nicht, welche Texte er da selbst geschrieben hat, aber das ist alles sehr wohl formuliert. Ich glaube, das ist einfach der Wettkampf-Typ Uli Hoeneß, der auch deswegen so unterschiedlich wahrgenommen wurde. Also eigentlich mit allen Leuten, ja auch Lembke, auch Daumen. Alle haben sich mit ihm versöhnt, ausgehend von Uli Hoeneß, weil Uli Hoeneß genau beobachtet hat, wer hat sich rund um seinen Steuerprozess, das ist für ihn glaube ich die größte Kränkung, dass ihm das passiert ist, da hat er genau beobachtet, wer hat sich wie verhalten. Und die beiden haben da einfach nichts gesagt öffentlich. Und das hat dann schon gereicht, dass er sich aber an sie erinnert hat und sich dann bei ihnen gemeldet hat und quasi seinen Frieden mit ihnen geschlossen hat. Weitgehend bei Lembke gab es noch so kleinere Auf und Ab, aber das ist ja so, kennt man ja mit so On-Off-Beziehungen. Aber ich glaube, für Uli Hoeneß ist das Teil des Spiels, weil Uli Hoeneß auch verstanden hat, was Fußball ist. Also Fußball ist natürlich ein tolles Spiel und ein Sport. Und es ist ganz wichtig, dass deutsche Feinde da erfolgreich sind international und so weiter und so fort. Aber Fußball ist Unterhaltung. Fußball ist ein Teil der Unterhaltung. Und Uli Hoeneß hat das, glaube ich, schon ganz früh in seiner Karriere erlebt und hat dann aber auch als Manager so gelebt. Und deswegen hat, glaube ich, das für ihn immer mit dazu gehört, dass man eben als Manager auch die Möglichkeit hat, nochmal so sein eigenes Spiel zu spielen, neben dem Spielfeld, vielleicht auch manchmal abzulenken von der eigenen Mannschaft, der eigenen Mannschaft ein bisschen Freiraum zu ermöglichen. Und deswegen war er da diese Mediendomptür über viele Jahrzehnte hinweg. Und als dann die digitalen Medien immer wichtiger wurden und als dann vor allem die sozialen Medien dazu kamen, ab 2008 und so weiter, kann man das ja ungefähr sagen mit Facebook und Twitter, da ist es ihn dann langsam entglitten. Denn das ist eine Art und Weise der medialen Welt, die er, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann. Also dass eben jetzt quasi hier wahrscheinlich jetzt schon Tweets geschrieben wurden zu diesem Abend und dann retweetet werden und hätte ich jetzt was ganz Schlimmes gesagt, dann wäre vielleicht auch schon irgendwie ein Aufreger draußen oder vielleicht sagst du ja noch irgendwie was richtig Schlimmes. Dann können wir das ja nachspielen. Sag doch mal, was da passiert ist 2012. Nee, ich lasse dich in Ordnung. Aber so wäre das Interview geworden zwischen uns. Vielleicht doch ganz gut, dass du abgesagt hast. Ich glaube, das ist ihm einfach fremd, weil es ja tatsächlich auch völlig pervertiert ist, die Medienzyklen, die heutzutage innerhalb von Stunden funktionieren und alles auf Aufmerksamkeit und auf Reichweite getrimmt.
Es gibt zwei Ereignisse in seinem Leben, wenn man das mal so sagen darf, die ihm vollkommen entlitten sind. Das ist Anfang der 80er Jahre der Flugzeugabsturz mit einer Propellermaschine, die als einziger von vier Insassen überlebt hat. Und dann ist es der Prozess in der Steueraffäre, wo er glaube ich zu Anfang auch nicht geglaubt hat, dass er da die Kontrolle verliert und letztendlich zu einer Haftstrafe verurteilt wird. Diese beiden Ereignisse, wenn du diese ganzen fünf Jahrzehnte überschaust, haben die irgendwas mit ihm gemacht? Oder hat das für ihn im täglichen Geschäft keine Rolle gespielt?
Ich würde noch ein drittes Ereignis dazunehmen, das war die sogenannte Daum-Affäre. Da war es auch quasi so, dass ihm die Deutung so über das entglitten ist. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, weil das geht in den privaten Bereich rein. Und ich finde, obwohl Uli Hoeneß so prominent ist, geht uns das nichts an. Weil der darf ja auch gerne Privatmensch sein. Beim Flugzeugabsturz habe ich ja auch im Buch genau versucht, öffentliche und private Personen zu trennen. Ich habe nur das zitiert, was er selbst gesagt hat. Da hat er immer gesagt, das hätte ihn nicht wesentlich verändert. Und seinem Verhalten ist es auch abzulesen. Also er war im Grunde nach dem Flugzeugabsturz so wie vor dem Flugzeugabsturz. Das heißt, da kann man jetzt vielleicht nichts feststellen. Bei den anderen beiden Dingen, wenn ich jetzt eben bei der öffentlichen Person Hoeneß bleibe, glaube ich, dass ihm das schon gezeigt hat, dass sich die Welt verändert hat. Denn sowohl das Daumen-Interview als auch dann die Berichterstattung rund um den Steuerprozess waren für ihn in dieser Art und Weise unerwartet. Und egal, was er gemacht hat, er konnte auch nichts mehr dagegen tun. Also bei Christoph Daum war das so ein Dreiklang aus, er gibt eine eigene Pressemitteilung raus, er macht eine eigene Pressekonferenz. Andere Leute positionieren sich auch. Aber egal, was er gesagt hat, die Aufregung wurde immer größer und größer. Und am Ende hatte er Glück, dass er aus dieser Nummer als öffentliche Person unbeschadet herausgekommen ist. Und beim Steuerprozess war es natürlich um ein Vielfaches noch mal extremer. Natürlich auch aus gutem Grund. Also das ist jetzt keine unberechtigte Aufregung gewesen. Wenn jemand Steuern hinterzieht, eine öffentliche Person ist und dazu vorher immer noch den moralisierenden Kaufmann gibt, dann ist es auch folgerichtig, dass da extrem drüber berichtet wird. Aber was diese beiden letzten, also Daum und die Steueraffäre, gemeinhaben, ist, dass es auch sein Privatleben und vor allem das seiner Familie betroffen hat. Ich glaube, das ist eine Grenze, bei der wir alle empfindlicher wären und die sicherlich auch ihn geprägt hat. Ich glaube aber, dass jetzt quasi die Deutung, wie ihn das geprägt hat, steht mir nicht zu, darüber zu spekulieren. Das könnte er nur selber sagen.
Der Flugzeugabstand, wo du zu Recht darauf hinweist, dass das eine sehr private Geschichte ist, auch wie sie verarbeitet wird, trotzdem so tragisch das Ganze ist, zeigt sie noch mal auch in den Tagen danach das Selbstverständnis von Paul Breitner. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man in dem Zusammenhang überhaupt über eine schöne Adägnote sprechen kann, aber Paul Breitner hat sich sehr sofort, er hat ein Länderspiel gespielt, hat von einem Absturz, es war ja auf dem Weg, auf dem Flug zu einem Länderspiel nach Hannover, hin. Als das passiert ist, Paul Breitner ist noch direkt nach Schlusspfiff in die Katakomben geahlt, ist sofort ins Krankenhaus gefahren und hat auch den Rücktransport organisiert, wie das so seine Art war, was sich dazu gebracht hat, dich mit einem Traumatologen auseinanderzusetzen, ob das denn so die richtige Art und Weise war.
Ich wollte das jetzt nicht werten, aber ich wollte doch noch mal wissen, was da eben ein Experte zu sagt. Also Paul Breitner hat dafür gesorgt, dass Uli Hoeneß in einer fast baugleichen Maschine zurückgeflogen ist, drei Tage nach dem Absturz, und er hat ihm das vorher nicht gesagt. Also er hat ihn zusammen mit seiner Frau aufs Rollfeld begleitet und Hoeneß wollte dann zu einem größeren Flugzeug abbrechen und Paul Breitner hat gesagt, na na, hier entlang. Und dann stand halt Uli Hoeneß quasi im Sinne einer Schocktherapie vor der Entscheidung. Habe ich jetzt in Zukunft Angst vor dem Fliegen oder überwinde ich jetzt gleich sofort dieses Trauma? Und da fand ich es insofern interessant, mit einem Trauma-Experten drüber zu sprechen, weil das eigentlich auch durchaus zeigt, wie wenig man damals über Traumata wusste. Also die Traumatologie gab es damals noch nicht. Nicht mal diesen Begriff des Psychotraumas, der wurde wirklich psychologisch verwendet. Und das war mir eben dann wichtig, das mit diesem Expertengespräch rauszuarbeiten, um dann eben den Menschen zu zeigen, also einfach nur drüber zu schreiben, ha, das ist ja lustig oder ist ja krass, dass der einfach zurückgeflogen ist. Das fand ich zu wenig, sondern ich wollte eben auch zeigen, damals wusste man es aber eigentlich auch nicht besser, denn es gab noch nicht mal dieses Fachgebiet. Deswegen habe ich diesen Experten noch zu Wort kommen lassen.
Wobei Paul Breiner wirklich großartige Kontakte offensichtlich zu Fluggesellschaften hat. Es gibt die Anekdote nach dem verlorenen, nach dem gewonnenen Halbfinale 1982 gegen die Franzosen im Elfmeterschießen, flog halt keine Maschine mehr zurück unmittelbar. Sie mussten ja dann nach Madrid möglichst schnell, das Halbfinale war in Sevilla. Und Paul Breiner hat das zumindest hier auf einer Veranstaltung erzählt. Da stand auf einmal kein Flieger mehr, dann habe ich einen Flieger besorgt und dann war keine Besatzung da und dann habe ich eine Besatzung besorgt und dann sind wir dann nach Madrid geflogen. Und dann fragt man sich manchmal, glaubt ihr das selbst? Also dieses Selbstverständnis von Paul Breiner, das fand ich auch überhaupt, wie er 40 Jahre hier später aufgetreten ist, wenn er gesagt hat, er kommt Felix zu Magath an, die Autogrammstunde ist vorbei, wir gehen jetzt essen. Alle mit und dann sind alle noch hinter ihm hergedackelt. Da kommen wir wieder zum Anfang der Geschichte. Das waren schon zwei oder sind schon besondere Figuren, also Alphatiere, seitdem sie in dieser Fußballszene aufgetreten sind.
Ja, also das Selbstbewusstsein möchte man vielleicht selber gar nicht haben. Genau, die kommen eben aus einer Generation, in der sie – also sie haben sehr viel Rückenwind erlebt, gerade das Wirtschaftliche habe ich ja vorhin vorgelesen, also bis die das erste Mal erlebt haben, dass in Deutschland eine Krise stattgefunden hat, das war die Ölkrise und da hatten die ja schon ihre Porsche. Also das war dann für die nicht mehr das Problem. Und gleichzeitig, das muss man aber auch dazu sagen, entstammen sie auch einer Generation, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie es bei Paul Breitner ist, aber die auch den Luxus hatte, wenn man es als Luxus bezeichnen möchte, die Care-Arbeit, nämlich alles, was mit Familie und Haushalt zu tun hat, komplett an ihre Frauen delegieren zu können. Also auch da ist es so und übrigens auch bei allen genannten großen De Crossmann und Tönnies und so weiter. Das ist eben auch eine Generation von Männern, die sich auf ihren Beruf extrem fokussieren konnte und wollte und die aber all das Sonstige, was in ihrem Leben auch gut gelaufen ist, nämlich Kinder, Familie und so weiter, delegiert haben. Und vielleicht sind das deswegen dann auch keine zeitgemäßen Karrieren mehr, zumindest für die Jetztzeit.
Bevor wir jetzt nochmal zu dem Kapitel kommen, was du mit Mount Everest überschreibst, sowohl beim Podcast als auch in der Biografie, möchten wir doch nochmal die Gelegenheit geben, vielleicht hier ins Publikum zu schauen, ob vielleicht der eine oder die andere eine Frage an die beiden hier vorne hat. Da würden wir uns über freuen, hier vorne direkt, da können wir ein Mikro mal…
Ja, mich würde interessieren, Max, das ist ja jetzt wirklich eine herausragende Persönlichkeit mit Uli Hoeneß, sich da direkt ran zu wagen und Uli Hoeneß hat ja manchmal auch sowas planierraupenartiges, wenn ihm was nicht passt, wenn er was vielleicht nicht mitmachen möchte. Du hast ja auch in den ersten Folgen geschildert, dass er da erst nicht so imused war. Hattest du denn auch teilweise Respekt davor, je nachdem wie sein Urteil schlussendlich ausfällt, dass es für dich dann auch schwierig werden könnte, vielleicht auch so in der Szene, im Sportjournalismus, dass du dann vielleicht auch verbrannt sein könntest unter Umständen auch oder schätze ich da seine Macht zu groß sein und vielleicht seine Güte so als zu gering vielleicht auch?
Nee, damit schätzt du mich als zu groß ein. Also was soll man an mir denn verbrennen? Ich dachte, dass du… Nein, nein, lass mich das kurz fertig sagen, weil ihr hättet ja alle den Rasenfunk weiter gehört, oder? Und zum anderen, das war ja glaube ich das, was ihn auch so deutlich in seiner Absage hat werden lassen, dass ich ja für ihn nicht zu greifen bin. Also was hätte passieren sollen? Hätte der FC Bayern mich nicht mehr akkreditieren sollen? Ich hatte bis dahin keine Akkreditierung beim FC Bayern. Hätten sie mir die Interviews mit Spielern verweigern sollen? Ich habe keine Interviews mit Bayern-Spielern. Also dahingehend hatte ich ehrlich gesagt gar keine Sorge, weil dadurch, dass ich so mein eigenes Ding mache und im Sportsteurilismus ein sehr kleines Blatt bin, gab es ja eigentlich auch nichts, was man mir hätte wegnehmen können.
Auch eine Frage. Christian Nerlinger hat ja eben gesagt, dass er deinen Podcast gehört hat und dir dann auch Feedback geschrieben hat. Das würde mich interessieren, ob auch andere Persönlichkeiten, die in deinem Buch vorkommen, eventuell mal, dass du weißt, dass sie das auch gehört haben komplett oder da Reaktionen gab. Und die zweite Frage ist vielleicht, wir sind ja hier in Dortmund und das hat ja auch im Leben von Uli Hoeneß hat Borussia Dortmund eine große Rolle gespielt. Vielleicht kannst du darauf noch mal eingehen, also welche Beziehungen entscheidend waren oder was ihn auch angetrieben hat im Verhältnis zu Dortmund. Das fände ich auch noch mal interessant.
Also es haben viele Leute den Podcast gehört, bei denen ich nicht gedacht hätte, dass sie ihn mal hören und auch viele der darin vorgekommenen Personen. Und es ist bis heute erstaunlich. Also tatsächlich war Elf Leben jetzt im Nachhinein das, was mich dann doch etwas bekannter gemacht hat. Also jetzt passiert es mir eben, dass wenn ich zum VfL-Buchen komme und mich da akkreditiere und da ganz freundlich anfrage, weil Akkreditierungen für Podcasts ja noch nicht so normal sind in der Bundesliga, dann sagt der Pressesprecher, Mensch super, jetzt kann ich Ihnen endlich mal sagen, Elf Leben war richtig cool. Oder es haben mich auch Leute teilweise kontaktiert, wo ich erst dachte, das ist jetzt irgendein Fake. Und dann waren sie es aber wirklich. Also ja, es haben ein paar Leute auch aus der Fußballwelt gehört und glücklicherweise war das Feedback dann auch positiv. Und zum BVB, Uli Hoeneß wusste immer ganz genau, dass es zum FC Bayern auch den Gegenpart braucht. Und er hat sich nie dafür zuständig gefühlt, aber er hat immer genommen, wer da so war. Wenn Werder da war, dann hat er gesagt, Werder ist richtig schlecht. Wenn Köln der Gegenpart war, dann hat er gesagt, das, was Daumbal mit Köln macht, ist ja unmöglich. Und dann kam eben irgendwann Borussia Dortmund und das hat aber durchaus auch eine andere Qualität gehabt. Denn Borussia Dortmund war Anfang der 90er, war das 92, als man gegen Juve ins Halbfinale im UEFA Cup gekommen ist. Das war quasi das erste Jahr, in dem der BVB einen größeren Etat hatte als der FC Bayern, weil man damals mit einer glücklichen Auslosung im UEFA Cup noch mehr Geld mit TV-Einnahmen verdienen konnte als in der Champions League, die ja dann erst gegründet wurde. Das gibt es dann später noch mal, dass zum Beispiel ein Christian Nerlinger zum BVB geht und dass auch manche Spieler nicht vom BVB zu Bayern wechseln. Unter anderem Karl-Heinz Riedle ist dann aus Italien zum BVB gewechselt, weil damals Dortmund höhere Gehälter gezahlt hat. Diese Phase im deutschen Fußball gab es auch, die war nicht sehr lange. Der FC Bayern hat dann überholt und ihr wisst dann alle, was dann auch 2005 passiert ist. Aber deswegen war Dortmund für Uli Hoeneß, glaube ich, ein sehr ernst zu nehmender Gegner. Er hat das nie leicht genommen und gleichzeitig wusste er, dass er aber immer den Gegenpart braucht. Und das erklärt ja dann auch, warum dann, als es Borussia Dortmund ganz, ganz schlecht ging wirtschaftlich, der FC Bayern dann auch mit Darlehen da ausgeholfen hat. Also auch der FC Bayern kann nicht alleine in der Bundesliga spielen, er braucht die Gegner auf Augenhöhe. Und ich glaube, das jetzige Verhältnis ist das, was Uli Hoeneß am liebsten ist, weil Dortmund sportlich nicht mehr gefährlich wird und es aber trotzdem immer kurz so aussieht. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das, was er haben möchte.
Eine Anmerkung, eine Frage, Anmerkung, eine ganz tolle Veranstaltung, total wertvoll und ein großartiges Gespräch hier. Also auch mit Christian Nerlinger ist er eine super Bereicherung von deinem tollen Buch. Eine Frage an Christian Nerlinger, die mich interessiert. Als Bayern-Fan, Kind, Jugendmannschaft, dann der Profi-Vertrag, großartige Sache, man lebt seinen Traum, dann wie ist das eigentlich, ich hör das manchmal von anderen Spielern, als ich dann Profi wurde, hörte das auf mit dem Fan sein. Wie war das bei dir? Und wie war das dann, als du dann zu Dortmund gewechselt bist, aus der Distanz dann auf den FC Bayern zu blicken, den Lieblingsverein der Kindheit?
Es ändert sich im Laufe der Zeit, also ich hatte das Glück reinzukommen in die Mannschaft im ersten Jahr Stammspieler zu werden, 30 Einsätze, neun Tore, Deutscher Meister und dort bis Bayern durch und durch. Dann ging es langsam los, man schießt ein Tor gegen Göteburg im Viertelfinale Champions League und die Journalisten fragen, haben sie sich ihr eigenes Grab geschaufelt? Wieso? Ja, weil jetzt Konkurrenz verpflichtet wird. Das kann ich auch so sagen, dass man weiterhin Sympathien für diesen Klub hat, wahnsinnige Erinnerungen hat, aber dass das Fan-Sein irgendwann tatsächlich aufhört. Sonst würde man ja auch nicht irgendeinen Schritt machen zum anderen Verein. Und natürlich dann noch mal extremer, wenn du auch als Sportdirektor hinter den Kulissen gearbeitet hast und das dann beendet. Also dieses Fan-Sein, also diese Sympathie, diese Liebe zum Spiel, die geht nie verloren. Und es war zum Beispiel auch bei uns, als ich dazugekommen bin bei Bayern München, hat es immer den Montagskick gegeben. Rummenigge, Hoeneß, Männerich, Jung und alle Mitarbeiter. Und danach sind wir zu dem, was da los war. Da ging es ums Abendessen. Da hast du gemerkt, diese Liebe zum Spiel, die kann dir nie jemand nehmen und die bleibt auch bestehen. Aber als Profi ist es dann tatsächlich so, dass es Sympathien gibt, dass man Dinge gut findet. Ich finde die Entwicklung beim SC Freiburg sensationell. Das gefällt mir wahnsinnig, wo ich sage, was da für Arbeit geleistet wird. Da hat man Sympathien, aber dieses Fan-Dasein und Fan-Gefühl, das verliert man im Laufe der Zeit.
Eine Frage zum Thema Paul Breitner. Du hast ja, Max, auch in deinem Vorhandbook herausgearbeitet, dass zu Beginn von Hoeneßs Manager-Karriere Paul Breitner und Hoeneß gemeinsam die Geschicke quasi geleitet haben. In den Quellen verzeihne ich, dass du auch die Bücher von Paul Breitner erwähnt hast, und da gab es da Punkte, also ich habe auch das eine Buch gelesen, da hat er zum Beispiel Sachen wie das Bankett nach Europa-Pokal spielen von Real Madrid, die wurden auch später bei Bayern umgesetzt. Meine Frage ist, hast du im Zuge der Recherchen herausfinden können, was eine Funktion möglicherweise Paul Breitner nach Ende seiner Karriere bei Bayern gehabt haben könnte, wenn es nicht zu diesem Vorfall auf dem Privatspiel in Asien gekommen wäre?
Das ist eine interessante Frage, weil Paul Breitner tatsächlich für sehr viele Funktionen beim FC Bayern immer mal wieder ins Gespräch gebracht wurde, und manchmal auch von Uli Hoeneß selbst. Also was eigentlich recht gut dokumentiert ist, aber alle Beteiligten wollen sich nicht mehr daran erinnern, ist, dass Rummenigge Präsident werden wollte in der Phase, in der Fritz Schere Präsident war, und Rummenigge und Beckenbauer kamen als Vizepräsidenten, dafür wurde die Satzung geändert, und es ist ja kein Problem auf Bayern JH. Haus. Und dann wollte aber Rummenigge gerne Präsident werden, und er wollte nach allem, auch was ich nachrecherchiert habe, dass dann Paul Breitner Uli Hoeneß ersetzt hätte. Wenn man heute beteiligte Personen darauf anspricht, erinnert sich niemand mehr daran. Also Paul Breitner konnte ich nicht drauf ansprechen, da war es ja nach acht Sekunden vorbei. Ich vermute aber, der hätte sich auch nicht mehr daran erinnert. Also bis hin zu direkt Beteiligten. Das alles ist scheinbar nie geschehen und komischerweise steht es aber in Zeitdokumenten aus dieser Zeit. Und durchaus später war Paul Breitner immer wieder im Gespräch. Ich meine, er hatte ja auch Funktionen, nicht nur als Ehrenspielführer, sondern es gibt ja auch so – jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt FC Bayern Originals, aber so heißen sie nicht – ehemals verdiente Spieler, die auch dann im Ausland für den FC Bayern werben und dort auftreten. Da hatte er Funktionen. Viel spannender, finde ich eigentlich die Frage, was wäre passiert, wenn Paul Breitner länger als eine Nacht Bundestrainer gewesen wäre. Denn das ist ja eine der kuriosesten Episoden, die allerdings auch sehr viel über unseren DFB aussagt, dass Paul Breitner tatsächlich für eine Nacht Bundestrainer war und dann schon daran gearbeitet hat, was er jetzt verändern würde. Und als dann am nächsten Morgen der DFB-Präsident darüber informiert wurde, du Paul Breitner, findest übrigens alles doof, was wir machen, dann hat man sich umentschieden und mit Uli Stieleke geredet, dann auch mit Erich Ribbeck geredet und am Ende wusste Uli Stieleke nicht, dass auch noch Erich Ribbeck kommt und da ist eins der ikonischsten Kicker-Cover entstanden, bei dem nämlich groß Stieleke drauf ist und dann steht drauf Stieleke wirds oder so ähnlich. Und dann mussten sie aber feststellen, ach nee, Ribbeck wird der Teamschiff und Stieleke soll nur der Co werden. Das war nämlich eine Last-Minute-Änderung, die dem DFB da noch eingefallen ist. Und das sieht bis heute, wenn man es weiß, dann sieht man das dem Cover anders, die da nachträglich quasi noch den Text ändern mussten. Und auch der ganze Artikel, der dreht sich eigentlich sehr, sehr viel um Stieleke und wenig um Ribbeck, weil das eben alles so eine konfuse Zeit war. Aber so war es eben beim DFB und Gott sei Dank ist ja jetzt alles strukturiert und klar und harmonisch.
Es wurde ja jetzt viel über Hoeneß und Rummenigge auch gesprochen, dass es Team Hoeneß gab, Team Rummenigge gab oder gibt. Und aus Dortmunder Perspektive würde ich den Watzke als Team Rummenigge einschätzen. Der Kontakt ist ja wirklich deutlich ausgeprägter. Jetzt haben wir ja die Krise des deutschen Fußballs mit dem Team Rummenigge, Team Watzke in der Führung. Würdet ihr euch mehr Hoeneß wünschen oder mehr Watzke und Rummenigge in der Zukunft des deutschen Fußballs?
Die Frage darfst du beantworten.
Ich finde, es ist jetzt mal Zeit für neue Kräfte, die gerne auch von außerhalb kommen dürfen und die gerne auch keine Männer sein müssen.
Das war's für heute. Ja, vielen Dank für die Beteiligung. Ganz kurz noch mal, wir haben es ja vorweg genommen, du hast es geschafft, du hast Uli Hoeneß zum Interview getroffen, was wirklich, wenn man sich den Podcast anhört, wirklich eine spannende Hinführung ist. Und du auch glaubhaft schilderst, dass das für dich so eine Art Olymp ist, wenn ich das mal sage, zumindest für dieses Projekt. Und wie war der Tag dann, als du da hingefahren ist? Ist das wirklich, wie hat man sich das vorzustellen? Ihr habt euch, glaube ich, in einer Gaststätte unterhalb verabredet, wo er wohnt. Also er kommt dann herab und hält Audienz oder wie ist das?
Bisschen so ist das. Also es war ein nervenaufreibender Tag, weil natürlich, ich wusste, ich veröffentliche ja meine Gespräche ungeschnitten, weil ich finde das ist die authentischste Form. Und damit hört man dann aber auch manchmal Gesprächsparts, die nicht gut laufen. Und ich komme auch manchmal nicht so gut weg, weil ich Dinge nicht weiß. Das ist ja auch bei Hoeneß passiert, dass sich der Name Riku Steinmann fiel mir da nicht ein. Das war mir sehr unangenehm im Nachhinein. Also man ist dann natürlich ziemlich aufgeregt und ich habe ja auch alle Technik selbst gemacht, weil ich aber auch unbedingt wollte, dass ich alleine mit ihm spreche. Ich wollte nicht einen Producer mitnehmen, der dann mir die Technik abnimmt. Deswegen war ich ehrlicherweise die Hälfte des Gesprächs am Pegeln, weil immer wenn er sich aufgeregt hat, musste ich ihn leiser machen und immer wenn er sich beruhigt hatte, musste ich ihn wieder lauter machen. Ich war die ganze Zeit ein bisschen wie David Guetta. Aber ansonsten war es interessanterweise dann genauso, wie ich es mir vorgestellt hatte. Und das hat mich sehr beruhigt. Denn wenn man sich – zu dem Zeitpunkt waren es glaube ich zweieinhalb Jahre – mit einer Person auseinandersetzt, dann wäre das ziemlich ernüchternd, wenn der ganz anders ist, als man erwartet. Aber es war dann so, wie ich es auch erhofft hatte. Und in dem Interview sind Dinge gut gelaufen, es sind aber auch Dinge schlecht gelaufen. Als Interviewer habe ich sicherlich auch Dinge gelernt aus diesem Gespräch. Und damals war ich ja gar nicht so glücklich, dass das noch klappt. Weil für mich in meinem Kopf war F-Leben endlich vorbei. Und dann ruft er an. Und ich dachte mir so, Mensch, Uli, das kann doch jetzt nicht wahr sein. Und damals haben aber schon alle anderen gesagt, also die wenigen Leute, die es wussten, die haben damals schon gesagt, nein, Max, das ist super, das bindet jetzt die ganze Geschichte ab. Und das wird toll. Und ich habe gesagt, ja, weil ich so ein bisschen früher melden können. Und ich hatte doch jetzt schon den Schluss geschrieben und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt im Nachhinein mit Monaten Abstand zu diesem Gespräch finde ich es aber auch gut, weil es tatsächlich den Podcast rund gemacht hat und es macht auch dieses Buch rund. Es ist nicht so, also auch die anderen Biografen haben mit ihm geschrieben, die haben gesprochen, die haben halt bloß nicht für ihre Bücher mit ihm gesprochen. Das habe ich ja letztlich auch nicht getan. Aber letztlich hat mir dieses Interview es ermöglicht, dass ich – im Podcast war es so, dass es mir wichtig war, dass ich das letzte Wort habe, weil ich das Gefühl hatte, also ehrlich gesagt, du, ich bin jetzt drei Jahre hinterhergelaufen, also jetzt will ich das Fazit ziehen. Tut mir leid, deine Chance war vorbei. Im Buch ist es tatsächlich so, das letzte Wort gehört Uli Hoeneß. Und ich finde, im Buch fühlt sich das auch sehr rund an. Man hört ganz lange mich, wie ich eben all meine Erkenntnisse, ihr habt es ja gehört, zum Besten gebe. Und der letzte Moment des Buchs gehört dann aber Uli Hoeneß und das war nur durch dieses Interview möglich und fühlt sich komischerweise genauso rund an wie der Podcast, zumindest für mich. Ihr müsst halt das Buch jetzt noch lesen und dann sagt er mir.
Christian, wie schätzt du das ein, dass Uli Hoeneß dann zu diesem Interview bereit war? Ist das auf jeden Fall keine Selbstverständlichkeit für ihn, oder?
Na ich glaube, dass Uli Hoeneß genau schaut, wer über ihn spricht, wie über ihn gesprochen wird und es da auch keine irgendwie Abstumpfungen bei ihm gibt, sondern dass ihm das wichtig ist. Und ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass er den kompletten Podcast gehört hat, das ist auf gar keinen Fall, er ist halt dafür ausgeschlossen. Aber ich glaube, er hat Feedbacks bekommen und ich würde, ich glaube, wenn er ihn gehört hätte, hätte er die eine oder andere Anmerkung. Klar. Aber ich glaube auch, wenn er ihn gehört hätte, dass er merkt, dass jemand versucht, die Person neutral und seriös mit sehr guten Quellen zu erkunden und wahrscheinlich auch aus diesem Grund bereit war, sich dann in einer Interviewsituation zu begeben.
Wenn du die Jahre der Zusammenarbeit des Erlebens, des Zusammenlebens, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, mit Uli Hoeneß Revue passieren lässt, was hat dich am meisten geprägt? Was hat dich am meisten beeindruckt? Was nimmst du aus dieser Zusammenarbeit, aus dieser gemeinsamen Zeit mit?
Die Energie, die Dynamik, jeder Tag, nie Langeweile, immer ist was. Uli Hoeneß, es wird dir nicht langweilig. Es ist was und es muss getan werden. Es ist sehr viel Mut dabei, auch mal Grenzen zu überschreiten, auszutesten, den Fußball auch so zu entwickeln, wie er das getan hat. Es war unglaublich facettenreich und er ist auch jetzt zehn Jahre – wir haben sehr unregelmäßig Kontakt oder sehen uns – aber trotzdem auch zehn Jahre, nachdem dieses Ende stattgefunden hat, hat er in meinem Kopf immer noch eine sehr entscheidende Persönlichkeit. Mit allen Höhen und Tiefen, aber wenn ich für mich nach zehn Jahren so ein Fazit ziehe, dann sage ich, ich habe ein positives Fazit, er ist für mich ein guter Mensch und er ist in dem, was er beruflich gemacht hat, ein unglaublich voraussehender Mensch gewesen, der den Fußball in Deutschland mitgeprägt hat und in der FC Bayern zu dem gemacht hat, was er heute ist. Und es hat die meiste Zeit auch wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht.
Max, Uli Hoeneß war jetzt vier Jahre dein Lebenspartner, zumindest Arbeitspartner, nur Projekt, wie man es auch immer sagt. Hat es sich gelohnt, welche Erkenntnisse hast du, oder was ist deine größte Erkenntnis, die du gewonnen hast? Ist Uli Hoeneß jetzt für dich anders, als er vorher war?
Also ja, ich hab jetzt auf jeden Fall ein differenziertes Bild zu Uli Hoeneß und vor allem ich hab für mich jetzt zumindest keine Lehrstellen mehr. Ich kann mir alles erklären und es liegt alles vor mir da und es ergibt jetzt ein schlüssiges Bild und deswegen habe ich jetzt so ein Stück weit meinen Frieden damit gemacht. Und was mir aber eigentlich geblieben ist, ist, dass ich tatsächlich über die Arbeit am Podcast und dann auch am Buch wirklich den deutschen Fußball viel besser verstanden habe. Und das beschämt mich fast ein bisschen, weil ich war ja schon vorher Sportjournalist und ich habe ja schon vorher viele Fußballbücher gelesen und so weiter. Aber jetzt habe ich wirklich nochmal – ich kann jetzt viel besser erklären, warum ist der Fußball so, wie er ist. Ich kann auch leichter darüber sprechen, wo würde ich persönlich mir wünschen, dass der Fußball hingeht. Und gleichzeitig – und das ist jetzt dann aber nichts, wofür ich die Verantwortung trage, sondern das hat sich so ergeben – gleichzeitig ist das jetzt auf einmal auch meine Rolle geworden. Also als ich noch den Rasenfunk, nur den Rasenfunk gemacht habe, da war ich im Sportjournalismus einfach der Nerd. Ich war einfach dieser weirde Typ, der wahnsinnig viel Fußball guckt, was keiner machen möchte. Und so wurde ich auch quasi von anderen Journalisten behandelt und auch zu solchen Themen befragt. Und jetzt ist es auf einmal so, dass ich jetzt dieser weirde Typ bin, der wahnsinnig viel Fußball guckt, der aber auch erklären kann, warum der Fußball als Geschäft so ist, wie er ist. Und das ist nur durch F.leben zustande gekommen. Und auf einmal führe ich ganz andere Gespräche, habe auch das Gefühl, andere Möglichkeiten zu haben. Das heißt, so ein bisschen habe ich jetzt vielleicht meinen Platz im Sportjournalismus gefunden dadurch.
Und wäre der deutsche Fußballer ein anderer heute, ohne Uli Hoeneß?
Ja, er wäre genauso groß und dominant und hätte alle anderen Sportarten verdrängt. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass der FC Bayern so krass dominant wäre. Und damit wäre es ja definitiv ein anderer Fußball. Vielleicht, ehrlicherweise aber auch ein für Nicht-Fans des FC Bayern besserer Fußball.
Das sei mal in den Raum geworfen. Genau, ich möchte mich bedanken, bei euch, die ihr am Sonntagabend Zeit genommen habt, hinzukommen, die ihr auch die Veranstaltung natürlich bereichert habt. Hier vorne macht es Spaß, über Fußball zu reden und einfach die Geschichte Revue passieren zu lassen. Dafür braucht man aber auch tolle Protagonisten. Und Christian, vielen Dank, dass du aus München extra angereist bist.
Danke schön.
Eine tolle Geste. Max, ich glaube, du spürst bei jeder Veranstaltung, ist ja mittlerweile eine dritte schon hier, wo du dein Buch vorstellst, wie sehr die Leute das wertschätzen, was du da fabrizierst hast die letzten Jahre. Dazu herzlichen Glückwunsch und die es noch nicht gelesen haben oder sich den Podcast noch mal anhören wollen, kann man ruhig sagen empfehlenswert. Unter dem Strich. Deswegen am besten selbst die Probe machen. Wir haben natürlich dort auch Exemplare, die jeder gleich erwerben kann. Sicherlich auch mit persönlicher Widmung noch. Ich glaube, Christian wäre auch noch bereit. Ich weiß, jetzt kennt er den Terminkalender heute Abend nicht mehr so, aber vielleicht kannst du ja auch noch mal das eine oder andere signieren. Großartig, vielen Dank. Hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich möchte mich bedanken mit zwei kleinen Präsenttüten. Dort haben wir auch – das ist übrigens auch ein Buch, wo wir so ein bisschen die Fußballgeschichte Revue passieren lassen. Da könnt ihr ja mal nachprüfen, ob das alles so stimmt. Und wenn nicht, macht die gute Flasche Wein dann auf und macht euch einen schönen Abend damit. Herzlichen Dank an euch beide und euch einen guten Abend. Vielen Dank. Keine dieser Veranstaltungen endet ohne einen ausgesprochenen herzlichen Dank an unser ganzes Team, was hier solche Abende möglich macht. Das Team der Gastronomie, an unser Team vom Anstoß Kulturprogramm, was federführend geleitet wird durch meinen geschätzten Kollegen Henry Walig, Dr. Henry Walig, unser großer Fußballhistoriker, der aber auch immer wieder die Ideen zu solch tollen Veranstaltungen hat und der unser Programm hier gestaltet. Gucken Sie auf unsere Homepage, was als nächstes ansteht, was als nächstes ansteht, Henry zum Beispiel haben wir ein Talk… So was, die Leichtunterhaltung machen wir auch. Aber wir haben, glaube ich, demnächst auch das Thema Fußball im Iran. Da geben wir auch wieder eine Podiumsdiskussion, sicherlich sehr interessant. An Kathrin Weber möchte ich auch danken, die immer hier das ganze organisatorische Drumherum gewährleistet. Und wie gesagt, das ist eine tolle Teamarbeit. Und so machen wir das hier im Fußballmuseum. Und bleiben Sie uns gewohnt, kommen Sie gerne immer wieder. Und wie gesagt, gehen Sie auch mal in die Dauerausstellung, hilft uns auch weiter. Vielen Dank nochmal an alle.
Und das war Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 49. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Wenn euch generell diese Porträtenatrigen Gespräche interessieren, dann könnt ihr natürlich das Tribünengespräch mit Holger Badstuber zum Beispiel hören. Der hat auch nochmal sehr ausführlich auf seine Zeit zurückgeblickt, nicht nur bei den Bayern, sondern auch bei den folgenden Vereinen, bei denen er gespielt hat, Schalke, Stuttgart und so weiter. Ist schon ein bisschen älter, diese Sendung, aber sicherlich deswegen nicht schlecht geworden. Euch danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, danke nochmal ans ganze Team vom Deutschen Fußballmuseum in Dortmund und euch eine gute Zeit. Bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu, wir freuen uns und bleibt vor allem gesund. Bis bald mal wieder, macht's gut! Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.